is all very well for the local authority
of Vans which run on diesel but not much
use for the care responders who use
petrol and actually getting to the point
where there is petrol available
and you don't do that by
attending to it on Monday and then
waiting a long time you have to attend
it on Monday and Tuesday and Wednesday
and Thursday and that really is very
difficult to do if you're doing an awful
lot of other things I tried to do it in
the fields that I preoccupy myself with
in resilience but I'm very conscious
that I didn't have enough time to do as
much as I should have done
that's extremely helpful thank you
may we take it from what you've told us
or Oliver then that the
issue of
resilience of preparedness and and
perhaps also
some of the other areas involving civil
contingencies such as the risk of Cyber
attack and so on and so forth
was not a formal area which was
assigned if you like to one or other of
the ministerial positions that you held
it was a it was a function or a
post-drawn area that you grew that that
you
devoted attention to and and which
perhaps
took up a larger amount of your time it
wasn't a formal
policy area for which you took full
responsibility by virtue of one or other
of those ministerial posts that's
correct all right
um
could you just help us please with
the the differences between the various
ministerial positions to which you've
made reference it is the chancellor of
the duchy of Lancaster a more senior
ministerial post than for example the
minister for the cabinet office
the chancellor of the duchy of Lancaster
is like the Holy Roman Empire and either
Helena Empire neither a Chancellor nor
much of a duchy and
um it's just an honorific
um uh an ancient honorific
um a minuscule proportion of my time
perhaps
um an hour a month was spent on duchy of
Lancaster business and that will be the
same for any
um Chancellor there's a perfectly well
World machine that looks after the
Queen's lands in Langston does not need
to be occupy minister
um uh my real role was as a so-called
Minister for government policy and
actually really under that I was simply
a jack of all trades uh Mr Fix It I did
what it was that the Prime Minister uh
wanted done
um and that was holding the Coalition
together making sure that our program
for government was implemented and
trying to fix crises as There Rose it
was really out of the third the fixing
crisis as they arose roll that I slipped
into resilience and became progressively
as I learned about it more and more
concerned about our state of resilience
or lack of it and became more and more
involved in it and eventually decided
that really I ought to or somebody to
spend their entire time doing it
whilst you're a minister was there a
position known as minister of
implementation we've heard evidences
that at some point there was the
creation of such a post and
um
all of a done I think it was the
minister for implementation
in 2018 and 2019 but there was no such
Post in in existence when you were a
minister was there during the Coalition
Danny Alexander the Mind liberal
Democrat counterpart and I were
effectively joint ministers for
implementation
our job was to make sure that the
Coalition program was implemented and in
a coalition of course that's a matter of
contractual obligation it's not just a
matter of will or desire so it was
vitally important to the sustaining of
the Coalition that we we were confident
that that program was being implemented
all ministers by definition start off by
and large as amateurs
um did to what extent did you have to
learn on the job in relation to the
field of emergency preparedness
resilience and response completely uh I
I think I can accurately say that when I
began it was entirely new to me
um I'd been in opposition shattered Home
Secretary for example so I had seen
um some of the issues arise but that's a
whole different thing from actually
trying to deal with crises and trying to
deal with preparation it was when I
actually sat in the Cobra room and
discovered that we were not properly
prepared to deal with a fuel tanker
crisis or to avert it discovered that
the Civil contingencies act emergency
Powers were powers for having an
emergency rather than preventing one and
discovered that it was only through the
army that I could actually get someone
to organize for the tankers to arrive at
the petrol stations in order to prevent
the strike being effective and thereby
ultimately prevent the strike that I
discovered that there was a old set of
problems here I knew nothing about and
that's when I began to learn about
and is one of the more difficult
features of being a minister concerned
with emergency preparedness resilience
and response that you're necessarily
having to deal not just with the Arcane
world of policy and guidance and the
General application of principles but
with to use a word that we've seen many
references to Opera operationalization
that is to say having to respond to
crises into civil emergencies and and to
have to take practical operational
decisions for for which perhaps one may
not be terribly Well Suited or trained
yes I I mean first of all an answer that
I should say
I don't think this is an area where
policy matters terribly policy matters
where there are disagreements about the
direction in which some aspect of the
country's deferred should go and your
government has a view and then it seeks
to find means of fulfilling that uh
there are no disagreements here that I'm
aware of right across the political
Spectrum we all want to prevent
emergencies arising we want to minimize
their impact when they do arise this is
not an issue for argument and debate and
policy
there's only one policy which is
minimize emergencies and make them make
ourselves as resilient to them as we can
it's all about the operations it's all
about finding out what actually is there
on the ground it's all very well having
committees and structures and guidance
documents and these can come out of your
ears without actually knowing that
you've got
the right things there you know you you
can't you can have a guidance manual
about PPE but if there's no PPE there it
won't be available to what extent whilst
you're a minister were documents such as
the
influenza pandemic strategy or the risk
assessment protocols and guidance
brought to your attention well they
weren't but for a reason which I've
described in my uh will contact will
come in a moment sort of to your request
that there be a number of reviews and
and to what the response was but but in
order to gain some understanding of of
the level
to which you had to dissent in terms of
looking at the guidance and the policy
documentation and the protocols and the
approaches the the the written strategic
material relating to how to respond to a
crisis was that the sort of material
which would find itself to ministerial
level
um
typically it did arrive for blessing at
the end of a very long uh bureaucratic
process that had led to its formulation
but but in the areas that I was focusing
on as I've explained in the statement I
was not focusing on pandemic flu because
I was advised that that was already
being very well dealt with and I
delegated that therefore to Clay Smith
may want to come back to that
it's a matter of regret on my part but
in the areas I was delving into
proactively the whole of our critical
National infrastructure which I believed
increasingly and still believe is wildly
under resilient
I was not spending time reading guidance
documents and policy documents I was
spending time with people who were
running the Telecom system the
grid the district Network operators the
ports the airports the people who ran
the supply chains for critical chemicals
and so on and and spending hours with
them hour after hour in an inquisitorial
mode rather as you're doing with me now
to try to find out whether rather than
all the documents and guidance they
actually had the things in place that
needed to be in place to make them
resilient so how does the system work in
a ministerial office sir Oliver in
relation to the
the signing off if you like
of important
strategies
policies or guidance
so take for example during your time
um in office there would have been and
there were produced a number of risk
assessments generally binaurally
and those risk assessments would be
drawn up
by reference to particularly particular
and different risks and they would be
revised and considered by any number of
government departments by external
advisors by Chief scientific advisors by
chief medical officers in relation to
health risks and so on and so forth
that biannual risk assessment would then
come to you as the minister and you
would be presented with it and and
presumably you would be asked to give
your assent to it
promulgation
yes but your description is accurate
that's to say I was I didn't know the
details but I was aware that each one of
these risk assessments had been through
this awesome process you described with
any number of experts and I was of
course in a diameter I mean I knew
nothing about
um the the science of the spread of
diseases or the signs of almost any of
the other things that might have come on
to the risk register and always I
expected to be an expert in the science
or the professional judgments so it was
of course absurd to suppose that I could
counteract or or
um uh overrule all these experts or even
be alive to to the particularly
difficult doctrinal or practical issues
which underpin the particular document
with which you were being presented well
I think that I should have said to
myself in retrospect
um not are all these experts wrong but
have they asked the right questions
because that is something an amateur can
do perhaps only an amateur can do that
in the sense you have to be outside the
system I think to agree to to be able to
ask that question and that's why
I came to the conclusion in gradually
that we needed a sort of red team that
was going to ask the right questions
because I didn't even know enough to ask
the right questions or to know whether
they'd ask the right questions
I I think in the case of the critical
National infrastructure by the end I got
close enough to the subject so although
obviously I can't run the electricity
system and I don't know
how the telecommunication systems
operates as an engineer does I didn't
know what questions to ask by the end
because I'd ask so many questions and
seen so many answers that I'd begun to
suspect the things I wasn't being told
you can't do that for for areas that
you're not deeply involved in
emergencies are by definition of course
not business as usual
is there a case therefore for a formal
system of training
of those ministers who are tasked with a
heavy obligation of dealing with civil
emergencies not only a case I think an
overwhelming case but that's just part
of a much wider need for training which
emerges I think extraordinarily from all
the papers that you've asked me to
review and which I got the sense of
gradually anyway and why I'm so very
glad to see in the uh the resilience
framework document the government's now
produced that there is to be an academy
I hope that rather than just dealing
with how to produce guidance and how to
write minutes and so on will actually be
about how to handle emergencies and
therefore how to exercise for
emergencies and therefore how to prepare
for emergencies to make sure that that
you can actually handle them effectively
and does that include therefore by way
of exercise or or training
enabling ministers to be able to better
discharge the functions imposed upon
them yes can I add one thing because I I
hope Milady that this inquiry will will
will make this point because I think
it's incredibly important
it if you're a minister responsible for
anything
a40i resilience but even
um you know really important things like
Health defense for six months
you could have training for the first
two months but by the time you finish
your training you'll practically
finished your job
if you're an official that does a job
that's related to the
crucial interest of the United Kingdom
for 18 months and you have training
which usually takes six months to
arrange and you know six months to
conduct again you by the time you know
you're off I by the end of my time
working on these things for
five years
with the exception of one or two people
in the Civil contingency Secretariat who
were continuing their role there a new
an awful lot I kept on coming across
officials in less than I did as an
amateur me is the amateur because they'd
actually been in post for next to No
Time whatsoever so it isn't just a
question of training it's a question of
training and having a system that keeps
both ministers and officials in post
long enough so they can use the training
is that a another way of saying that the
the revolving door aspect of
some ministerial appointments and
official appointments
tends to undermine
experience
efficacy
and the ability of ministers and
officials to be able to do the job with
which they're tasked I strongly believe
that it does it I think that's true as a
general proposition but we're not here
to discuss the whole of British
government in this crucial respect I
think having a minister responsible
who's there right the way through a
government and with officials who are
committed to it from beginning to end
and and with luck longer than that in
their careers is really critical to
success Oliver can I just ask
you describe the revolving door and I
think we're all familiar with it across
government is that because you think
there is a trend to have a revolving
door with whatever government whatever
political Hue or because there is a
revolving door in this particular area
because it isn't considered to be a good
career stop
I think probably both my lady I I
I'm pretty certain that the entire
structure of the Civil Service means
that you can't really make progress in a
career without going through endless
different jobs one after another
child regard is a disaster for the
country particularly the disastrous in
the case of things that have very long
lead times and we're learning from
experience is critical and as to
ministers
um of course the exigencies of our
parliamentary democratic system make it
difficult to maintain continuity in in
every post but in this particular domain
if we were really taking it with the
seriousness we need to take it I think
we would have people who were there
right through and I I thought one of the
very good things about the way that
David Cameron ran this aspect of RFS was
that I was allowed at least to learn so
that by the end I really did know much
more than at the beginning
throughout the annual witness statement
you made reference to a specialist
committee called the National Security
Council threats hazards resilience and
contingencies committee
which we believe
[Applause]
what was commenced around the time I
think that you became Minister for
government policy but it was a committee
um which is very much within your brief
because you and David Cameron agreed
that they're ought to be a specialist
unit in the cabinet office
which would deal with matters such as
Horizon scanning which would feed into
that committee
whether or not the cabinet subcommittee
structure gave
as much weight to the issue of Hazards
and civil emergencies as it did to the
issue of
threats
National Security threats of the type I
I don't know
terrorist outrages
cbrne
attacks the behavior of Rogue States and
so on and so forth was there equality
do you believe between the two systems
or was the
system that dealt with hazards
crowded out to some extent by the focus
on threats
I think there is always a danger
um that
um threats are
um
more considered in Whitehall than
hazards because there's a huge apparatus
dealing with threat
mod the foreign office the agency's
security agencies uh the National
Security advisor on and on
whereas
there hasn't been up till now though I
hope there now will be with the head of
resilience and and if the man Alexander
suggestions for an integrated management
system were adopted or indeed very
similar to what the ryecroft review I
now see recommended in 22 maybe we could
we could create a if not equivalent at
least a a counterbalancing
power in Whitehall pushing for
consideration of of things that aren't
threats so I think the answer to your
question is that it was over balanced
towards threats
but uh may I just point out something
else which gets lost in the
dichotomy threat hazard
actually
for most of our fellow citizens for
people who were breathed in covert or
people who were affected by any of the
other disasters which have reflected our
nation over many
decades and centuries actually it's the
impacts account and not the causes
and whether a biological agent is
released by nature or by a state actor
or non-state actro terrorist whether the
whole of our critical National
infrastructure goes down because there's
a space where they're all because
there's a Cyber attack by a malicious
party
it doesn't matter from the point of view
of the way we prepare to respond and the
response we exhibit
it's the impact that we need to deal
with on behalf of our people in
particular the most vulnerable people
the people who are vulnerable to that
impact
and unless you focus on impacts you
can't focus on the right vulnerabilities
because it's not the cause that causes
some people to be more vulnerable than
others it's the impact that causes some
people to be more vulnerable to others
old people may be more vulnerable to
some impacts young people to others and
so on so it's it's not so I mean
although I do think it's important to
separate between threats and Hazards
because of this over balancing towards
preoccupation with threats because of
the structure of government and the
weight of the money
actually I think the most important
shift to achieve is a shift from
focusing on causes to shifts to a focus
on impacts and dealing with impacts and
preparing to deal with impacts and
minimizing impacts and particularly
minimizing impacts for the most
vulnerable people in relation to that
impact
does it follow from what you've said to
Oliver that
going forward the system for the
assessment of risk for the consideration
of response for the development of
resilience
needs in a general sense to focus more
on impact as opposed to likelihood or
cause absolutely and you introduce an
important element that I hadn't
mentioned which is this question of
likelihood
um
I have great respect both for economists
and for the treasury uh genuinely it's
not a side remark
but there's a terrible danger in
treasuries the world over and amongst
economists the world over that they're
fixated with discount rates and
probabilities so if event X
has a low very low probability of
occurring and is likely to occur a long
time away when you multiply the
probability Low by the discount rate
high you've come to the answer that it's
not worth worrying about it compared to
things which are right in front of your
nose
and this is a very bad mistake because
events with huge impacts that are very
unlikely and may not occur for many
years if they do occur will nevertheless
have huge impacts and as we've
discovered those are in every sense
human terms and economic terms
incredibly costly
so I think it's vital not only that we
focus on impacts but that we focus on
major impacts that isn't to say we
should ignore the minor ones but
actually I think we're pretty good at
handling the minor ones it's the major
ones that we're not properly prepared
for
um
Milady has procured a copy of a book
called apocalypse how found I think an
all good book shops but it's it's your
book
do you say in your book
that there has been a failure
by virtue of over-reliance on statistics
and probabilities that the system should
focus remorselessly on worst case
scenarios without worrying in the least
about How likely these are to occur
this ought to be obvious
but it will seem quite counter-intuitive
in any established bureaucracy because
bureaucracies are used not only to cost
benefit analysis of the of the sort that
is so destructive of fall back option
planning
but also to the Allied pursuit of
probability analysis
so are you saying sir Oliver that
the danger
and and it is a trap of course into
which the country fell
is of being unprepared for an event
which although it may be less likely may
have colossal impact
yes exactly uh I mean my great
regret about not having focused on
um pandemic flu because I was advised it
was being well looked after is not
actually about pandemic flu I might or
might not have been able to improve
preparedness for pandemic flu but that
it might have occurred to me if I had
focused on that
that despite the fact that all the
scientists had concluded and no doubt
they were right
that there was a very tiny probability
by comparison with the probability of
pandemic flu of some other catastrophic
uh pathogen
it might have occurred to me to say well
okay there's a tiny probability but as a
matter of fact can we for a tiny amount
of money prepare properly to deal with
it in advance and that would be the
right question to ask
now you made reference a few moments ago
to the reviews that you ordered be
carried out whilst you were a minister
and you made reference in fact to your
Junior ministerial colleague Chloe Smith
MP could we have please on the screen
one three four zero four
at page one
that this is a memo dated the 18th of
January 2012 copied to a number of
people including
um your
private secretary as well as the private
secretary to
Francis Moore to MP and a number of
senior officials and it's headed
Minister for political and
constitutional reform cabinet office
briefing for ministerial review of the
UK's resilience to pandemic influenza
and you will see that the memo concerns
a prospective meeting with Anna subri MP
to review the UK's resilience to
pandemic influenza
if you look at page three please
paragraph 12
you and Oliver lettwin will be writing
to the prime minister with your findings
we'll discuss with you when and what
form this takes but this may be some
months from now
consequently if you have particular
concerns with the adequacy of existing
plans or the department of Health's
knowledge of them we suggest you use the
meeting to commission to upon how to
update you on progress in a few months
so is this a memo in fact your
ministerial colleague but it concerns
does it not
the series of reviews that you
instructed be done into various aspects
of civil contingencies
well we should distinguish
um
there were
those areas that I
didn't commission I undertook the review
so with the critical National
infrastructure
I didn't have meetings with other
Departments
of the sort that's represented here
I spent as I say many many hours
drilling down into the detail with the
actual people operating the systems in
question
because my officials in the Civil
contingency secretary at
at the very beginning said to me this is
the area of our national life that we
think is least well prepared and so that
I didn't have an infinite amount of time
at my disposal I decided to focus on
that and drill down into it so I didn't
ask other people to do that I did that
very personally I sat there hour after
then of course there was all the rest of
our planning pandemic interface yes but
also all the sectors that there's
another memorandum in in the uh dossier
here uh which is similar to this but
relates to the care sector for example
in all of those sectors uh I asked Clary
Smith uh to uh to hold a series of much
less detailed uh meetings assuming that
the Department's in question under the
lead government Department model which
you may want to discuss in a moment I'm
not a great believer in but nevertheless
would would be concerned with
preparations in those sectors and her
job was simply to interrogate them and
make sure that they were on the job all
right could we please have a look at
page six of this
document that there's a reference to
maybe back one page thank you very much
in the middle of the page there is this
heading new case events of other
diseases with pandemic potential so that
is to say non-influenza diseases
the applicability of pandemic influenza
planning to other scenarios is good and
continues to develop
obviously the passage of time
demonstrated that that was not an
entirely accurate prognosis
this field of pandemic influenza
planning and planning for other
scenarios was that one of the areas in
which you were able yourself to carry
out a review now you're shaking your
head for the transcription it was not I
was advised as I say that that was under
good control as reflected in this
official briefing and therefore I made
the mistake of not looking into it
myself can you play
could you please tell me lady a little
bit more about the way in which you
asked
whether this was an error which required
your personal attention and
how the response came back to the effect
that this was an area in which we were
particularly well prepared and therefore
did not require
your personal assistance yes and
internet I I mean I will of course
answer that I should start by saying I
don't exonerate myself because actually
I probably should just have paid no
attention whatsoever to this advice um
nevertheless I did what happened was
this when I took on the job it was as I
say in the context of the fuel tanker
crisis and I was dealing with things
minute by minute
when I had time to draw breath and to
consider what had happened during that
uncrisis because we've managed to avert
it
and what it showed about lack of
resilience planning I thought I I really
should begin a set of systematic reviews
to find out whether there were other
areas like fuel delivery where we were
not well prepared for a crisis and uh so
I asked the CCS how should we do this
and what what uh is that a reference
Secretariat I'm very sorry
um and I was of course aware
that the national risk register or the
National Security risk assessment or you
know whichever of these are the
documents one refers to put
pandemic flu High uh both on impact and
on probability so it was an obvious
thing to put high on my review and I
said to them perhaps we should begin
with this and they said Minister that
would be a mistake because uh there's
going to be a full exercise which became
I think exercise cygnus it did uh there
is already a desktop uh exercise plan
which I think was called Signet
uh there is an indefinite amount of
attention being paid to this by the
government Chief scientist and his team
which I think was true uh there is a
great deal of attention focused on it
from the chief medical officer I think
was true as well uh and uh its risk
which is uh I I hate to use this word
but it was used frequently in Whitehall
owned by the Department of Health and uh
it you'll really just be Reinventing the
wheel why don't you focus on critical
natural infrastructure which is much
less well uh investigated
and I followed that advice as I say
actually it's it it's absolutely not an
excuse for a minister alas because you
can always ask
the the following question you don't
have to to accept the advice you can say
well okay I I hear that advice but
actually I still would like to look at
it and that is actually what I should
have done and it's a matter of lasting
grip I didn't but I didn't
and therefore sir Oliver does it follow
from that that
between the time when you ask that
question
and the time that you left ministerial
office so essentially 2011 to 2016.
there was no effective or at least no
effective detailed ministerial
consideration of the area of pandemic
influenza planning or Associated non
influenza
pathogenic planning this was an ERA
which you yourself
played no role in supervising the last
partial question
is absolutely right I myself did not
I just checked from time to time with
the chief scientist and the chief
medical officer that they were content
it was progressing and had Chloe Smith
doing what you see from these documents
and uh so so far as that part of your
question is concerned therefore the
answer is yes but uh it doesn't follow
from that there were no other ministers
who were dealing with it in detail of
course the the health department
contained ministers who were dealing
with it as I understand in detail you're
talking here at the cabinet office you
were the minister for resilience
preparedness
and in a broad sense civil contingencies
yes yes
could we have please one three four one
three four one five
on the screen and at page two
thank you
this is a a memo date of the 28th of
January 2013. it's a memo from the Civil
contingency Secretariat and it concerns
the review of UK resilience planning
which which has been conducted by but
not as you've described by you at the
top of the page there is a reference
to
um
perhaps we could go back one page
actually it might be a little easier
and then down to the bottom of the page
on the issue of countermeasures for
pandemics the challenges of ensuring a
proportionate response early on in a
pandemic when knowledge of the virus was
limited when noted
and then this right at the bottom of the
page mpcl questioned whether the
stockpiles of countermeasures provided
protection
and then over the page
perhaps not go to the top of the page
from other
non-influenza pandemic disease risks
so the issue is plainly raised there as
to whether or not the stockpiles for
influenza pandemic would be sufficient
for other non-influenza pandemic to
risks was that a a question or an issue
which was ever brought specifically to
your attention no uh it I obviously
received both the briefing and the
um account of the meetings that um Chloe
Smith had so I will have seen these
these documents
um uh and uh I uh to that extent it was
brought to my attention and it looked as
though as you can see from these
documents
there was a consensus in Department of
Health and the health protection agency
that
um this was
allowed to put this so ludicrous in
retrospect but um under control
the evidence may show
it's a matter entirely for my lady that
that there were a number of strategic
flaws
in the United Kingdom's approach to
pandemic planning as it turns out
you've mentioned
one of them already in your witness
statement a long-standing bias in favor
of
influenza and diseases that had already
occurred in particular the the 1918
H1N1 Spanish Flu pandemic
there may also have been a
failure to appreciate properly that
viruses were
unpredictable with variable
characteristics and therefore
the next pandemic May well very well may
very well not be a influenza pandemic
but be a non-influenza viral respiratory
pandemic with just as catastrophic
consequences because of high
transmissibility and deadly severity
and there also appears in the risk
assessment process to be a failure
to consider multiple scenarios and
there was an approach by which there was
a cause agnostic
approach that is to say a failure to
consider the specific
nature of a possible future pandemic
and and because
the worst case scenario was focused on
that there may have been a tendency
stop and think well
does there really have to be 820 000
deaths in the worst case scenario for a
pandemic influenza what about trying to
stop it before it gets that bad so
preventing
the terrible consequences from ensuing
as opposed to dealing with the terrible
consequences once they have ensued those
are all aspects of of arguably strategic
failure to Think Through the issues
you've referred in your witness
statement to the need therefore for
group think to be eradicated to be
challenged for
red teams to be put into place to
challenge orthodoxies to ask the
questions that have to be asked
what did you mean by the reference to
Red teams and the need to challenge
group think
um I I I'm not a will answer very much
want to answer but may I just before I
do
say that
I I doubt that the the
right analysis is that there was
um
a a set of
um uh experts who've got it all wrong
I think it's more likely
the the what happened was that the fact
that it goes back to the Impact versus
cause issue and the likelihood versus
impact issue I suspect that what
happened was that the scientists and the
Medics all came to the conclusion that
the most likely thing was pandemic flu
and that other things had a much lower
chance of success of success in in
attacking us and that
uh therefore that attention should be
focused on pandemic flute if they had
been focused on impact rather than on
cause
they might have uh observed that it was
very likely that whatever particular
virus it was that attacked us
would require to be tested to be traced
to have PPE associated with it to have
vaccines developed for it and so on
which are dealing with the impact and as
you say minimizing it in advance trying
to avoid having a catastrophe rather
than or minimize the capacity rather
than simply handling it uh and I think
that that was the mistake that that was
a strategic error to which you you refer
uh and I think if if we were to reorient
our resilience planning towards impacts
and to being prepared for them uh we
could make much better progress and
indeed in some respects uh even at my
the end of my time for other reasons to
do with ebola for example I pressed for
the vaccine Network which Mark walput
then took forward with Chris witty and
it it did happen and I think was a very
helpful thing although it wasn't
developed specifically for the the virus
we were attacked by because I knew
nothing of it but I did see from Ebola
that there was a
a need to have a much better system for
producing vaccines
and I think it's very clear if you look
at the results of exercise Alice which
went on uh at the very end of my time
and was implemented or perhaps not very
well implemented after my time uh
actually it had looked at the question
of the scaling of testing which Matt
Hancock refers to in his evidence or the
lack of ability to scale testing and it
also looks at the question of the uh
rollout of of uh tracking data so these
things were known that they were not
being attended to because people were
not thinking about impacts in general
they were mono maniacally focused on
pandemic flute this is exactly why I
think a red team is needed and what do
you mean by a red team how how in future
can
Orthodoxy be challenged effectively
within the confines of a bureaucracy in
in the confines of a government system
it can't be challenged within the
confines of the normal bureaucratic
system because
officials are just like the rest of us
they would like their careers to
progress
and if you're a member of a team and you
start being a frightful nuisance it is
not a career enhancing move
so they need to be separate they need to
be accountable to
a different person than the person who's
responsible for the thing that they're
meant to be inquiring about
um whether as I prefer
they'd be completely outside government
or whether they be within government
but somehow sufficiently insulated so
that they their careers can progress
notwithstanding causing trouble for
colleagues in government
is is I suppose a matter for choice but
the crucial thing is that there be this
is not expensive in certainly but just a
a smallish number 20 or 30 people with
the relevant expertise because one of my
problems in all of this obviously was as
you rightly described it as an amateur
um this should be done by professionals
so you want someone in the red team who
all right may not be as expert as the
government Chief scientist but
nevertheless it's a plausible credible
scientist of credible medic a credible
credible industrialist and so on and if
if they're sitting there and they're
saying well hold on you haven't asked
this question becomes very difficult not
to start thinking about it and at the
moment there is no such mechanism in
place so you mentioned earlier the
possibility of a new
statutory resilience Institute and and
we'll come on to that in a moment
how would such a body whilst providing
challenge to group think and Performing
the the red team function of which it
which you've described how would it
though be able to exercise the political
control
or or how would it exercise the
political influence to which you made
reference earlier in terms of being able
to to be near the Prime Minister and to
make sure that what is to be done
is done is Caridad is put into effect
well I I I'm delighted you mentioned the
premises because I don't think it's a
matter of political influence or
political power or the power to do
things it's a matter of whether this red
team reports quite directly to the
minister of resilience if there is one
full-time proper and the prime minister
right if they do things will happen if
if they're terribly sorry if if they're
siphoned off into reporting to some
elaborate set of um internal committees
and bureaucracies nothing at all will
happen it'll be absorbed and re
um it will re-emerge as much
has to go directly to the people who can
then say this can't be business as usual
the red team has pointed out we're
missing something what is going to be
done about it
you refer to mush
um in November 2015 you wrote an article
called five principles for getting
things done in Whitehall
principle one
volume is usually in inverse proportion
to effectiveness
and you say this the longer the document
be it legislation strategy or a simple
submission the less effective it is for
advising ministers communicating with
the public or getting whatever results
you're looking for
whilst you were a minister what view did
you form about the
profusion of paperwork that
the sheer number of
policy documents guidance documents
strategy material
and so on
I formed the view that it was highly
counterproductive I I you will have seen
my letter to the Prime Minister
establishing the notifying that I was
establishing The Horizon scanning
um uh for viruses after Ebola that he
and I had agreed we will have observed
it's a page long it was an absolute rule
for me I wrote endless memoranda to the
Prime Minister and that role as you
might imagine was an absolute rule of
mine that if I couldn't get it on one
page the maximum it would ever be is two
because I knew he was very busy and I
wanted him to be able to find out what
in essence I was trying to say to him on
the other side I was unfortunately it
was part of my role
responsible for receiving every
public-facing document produced by Her
Majesty's government they all came
across my desk
and
some of them were many times longer than
the
material warranted and I started a
process of putting in three jars green
yellow and red tags that my private
office very kindly arranged for me so we
could keep track of how many of these
documents were ludicrously overweight
and incomprehensible and uh it was about
a third or third a third a third were
pretty good and quite short and clear a
third were not very good and a third
were totally catastrophic and on the
catastrophic ones I sent them back
and I asked for them to be produced at
much lesser length in most cases I got
back something less than a quarter of
what I'd started with
it then often required further work to
get it to be clear what the person was
saying we could sometimes then get it
down to half of that length there's a
huge overproduction of large documents
man and Alexander are pretty eloquent
about this and they're right yes
although their own report of course did
weigh into the monsters 321 it's too
long but otherwise it's right
um
Milady has heard evidence
that if
if you happen to be a local resilience
forum and task for the primary duty of
responding locally
the duty of preparing for emergencies
and then also responding to them
you would have to be familiar with
cabin office produced documents such as
the concept of operations documented 80
Pages the revision to emergency
preparedness document at 591 Pages
multiple versions of a document called
emergency response and Recovery there
are National resilience planning
assumptions engagement with and guidance
for emergency responses Jessup paperwork
local risk management guidance
humanitarian aspect guidance Department
of Health guidance pandemic influenza
strategic framework guidance and so on
and so forth
do you believe that there is a case for
a radical rewrite
of the available policy
strategy planning documentation I don't
think it's just a case I think it
obviously needs to happen but
if it happens without having a
well-organized central
um a team under a head of resilience who
has direct access to the Prime Minister
and is parallel to the
National Security advisor
it will be wasted effort because it will
just dissipate through endless
consultations and committees all around
Whitehall and the simplification
exercise will become a complication
exercise so
what's critical is to have a group of
people who are determined to produce
Clarity and then set them to the task of
producing Clarity out of what is
currently much too unclear and much too
verbose
Now sort of May return just to some
specific
um issues and and areas on which
I want to ask you for your views before
you do Mr kissim Trump going back to the
point about you just made about the head
of resilience and a specialist team
given the points you made about somebody
having the heir of the Prime Minister
would your head of resilience be an
independent
person with an independent agency or
would it be somebody
ministerial like you had the year of the
Prime Minister
well there are various models around the
world
and some of them do have an agency
um
and of course we have agencies for some
purposes
and that is a possible model
I don't personally favor it because I
think there is a risk that in this
absolutely crucial function Central to
the purposes of government as a whole
it's very important that the person
heading the work and the people working
under them have direct access to the
Prime Minister and that's much more
easily done from within the central
government than anywhere else
I don't think it's just a question of
having a minister however I think there
needs to be as is foreshadowed in the
framework uh the resilience framework
just published by uh Oliver Darden a
head of resilience who is an official
who is parallel in stature to the
National Security advisor and has as the
National Security advisor has direct
access to the Prime Minister if you had
that combination of a full-time senior
cabinet minister for resilience
exclusively and a head of resilience
parallels National Security advisor I
think you would find that it worked as I
worked with Jeremy Haywood when he was
cabinet secretary on the police
implementation front he and I would meet
for an hour or so each day and we'd go
through the various questions of what
had or hadn't been implemented and I
would ring ministers and he would ring
permanent secretaries and often enough
by the end of the day we had actually
managed to get something done
and that's what you need as a sort of
pincer movement and you need those
people then to be able to walk into the
prime minister's office without Too Much
Ado and without having to schedule it
weeks off and say we've had a problem
here
we need your help in commanding that
something we do that I think would be
the most effective model but I
understand that there are people who
think that and there are reasons why
they might think that an independent
agency would be better less captured by
the system and so on I don't discount
that possibility I just think it's
less perfect
in your statement you refer to you see
this the working relationships
are as least as important as any
structure systems processes plans and
policies
um
doesn't appear to have changed
dramatically between 2011 and 2020.
can you recall therefore what the
position was in relation to the nature
of working relationships but firstly
Regional bodies and secondly the default
administrations from the viewpoint
of a United Kingdom minister in the
field of civil contingencies well
um
by the time I uh was dealing with
resilience issues
the government officers of the regions
had been abolished indeed in 2011 yes I
think fairly early in 2011 it must have
happened
um uh therefore I can't comment on uh
relations with them uh or how effective
they were I'm very sympathetic to the
view that's taken in some of the papers
I've now read as a result of the inquiry
including man Alexander that
it would be helpful to have a regional
tier uh coordinating uh local resilience
forums
um uh I hadn't thought of it before
reading these papers but I I see now
that that might well be a useful thing
um uh I can of course comment on
relations with the devolved
administrations
um not actually in relation to the
resilience planning that I was involved
in because when it came to the critical
National infrastructure and trying to
make it more prepared for various kinds
of impact that was an England exercise
because it the uh the critical National
infrastructure is a devolved matter and
I would not have succeeded in doing the
kind of inquisitorial work that I was
doing with the English providers of the
structures the the infrastructure uh in
the revolved administrations however
when it came to handling specific crises
so for example flooding uh um Ebola
um uh the fuel tanker crisis
we did have repeated
involvement of the devolved
Administration senior repres sentences
that evolved administrations appearing
in Cobra usually by video and I had
offline uh pretty continuous
conversations with for example John
Swinney who was then I think the deputy
first minister in Scotland
and I have to say that that although as
you might imagine
there was some friction with the
Scottish Administration when it came to
constitutional issues have had
Independence and Union there was no
friction when it came to dealing with
these that I could observe when it came
to dealing with these issues uh uh I I
uh and indeed indeed with with I was I
was at Brighton when the Brighton bomb
occurred I'm not a a lifelong devotee of
the IRA but I had a perfectly sensible
conversation with McGinnis about doing
things in Northern Ireland in the
context of these crises my experience
was you could do business with the
devault administrations perfectly well
on the basis of establishing some degree
of personal trust and limiting the scope
of the discussion specifically to
something where we both had an equal
interest and they as much as I wanted to
protect their populations
resilience is as if you've all already
observed a devolved issue
but pandemics
don't recognize borders and therefore
would you agree that any proper system
of emergency preparedness and response
must have in place structures for
dealing with
other territories
are the nations in the United Kingdom
where there will have to be a joined up
response
yes I think that's particularly true
with biological agency although
uh for example in relation to the
electricity grid there is of course a
deep interconnection with Scotland and
indeed while we're at it with France and
therefore I had discussions with the
devault administration in Scotland and
with French counterparts when I was
concerned with the protection of the
grid so it it yes you have to involve
all those who are involved and if you're
looking at impacts you'll quickly
discover who is involved and the impact
of a virus is very likely to be
Nationwide or indeed as we saw in this
case global
but your answers are Oliver
appeared to indicate that the
connections that you forge with the
devil administrations were based more on
ministerial inclination and your own
personal involvement than on a
formalized system of
committees or or some body
which would allow the default
administrations and the UK government in
Westminster to be able to to liaise and
plan properly and fully
was there not in place that formal
structure did the system in fact depend
too much on ministerial inclination
I don't know what I think about that I
that half of me wants to say you're
right it was like you are factually
right there was not such a formal system
uh and half of me wants to say that
you know that sounds like a gap the
other half of me says actually you can
create any set of formal institutions
you want but if if everyone arrives
ready to come to blows you won't get
anywhere if you don't have any formal
system but you have good personal
relationships you can probably get it
done
pretty well informally so well isn't the
answer that you need both uh you don't
need an overly
ossified system but but you need a
system by which everybody
can expect to play their part and and
can envisage attendance and and they can
attend and do what needs to be done
alongside good personal working
relations that would be the ideal yes I
agree all right just before Mr Keith
goes on sort of a you mentioned working
relationships with Northern Ireland and
with Scotland do the same apply to Wales
I didn't as it happens have
um uh oh sorry I there's one occasion
when I did have relationship with with
the Welsh Administration which is in
relation to flooding which happened to
involve them as as well uh uh uh as as
uh England
um
and I think the same applied they were
they were they were present at relevant
Cobra meetings by video we had a
perfectly working relationship as it
happens in the other cases I was dealing
with Wales was not a particularly
material issue
also in your statement you addressed the
issue of the need for exercises and you
states that you believe that the United
Kingdom government should regularize the
practice of simulating responses to a
variety of whole system emergencies by
carrying out at least two such
large-scale simulations in each
Parliament
um
putting aside the resource implications
and and putting aside the undoubted fact
that such exercises are difficult
complex things to arrange
why
would exercises with such regularity
have a demonstrably beneficial impact I
mean if if there is an exercise for
example every five years
um
and recommendations and actions which
flow from the exercise are properly
implemented and acted upon
would that not be sufficient for the
foreseeable future release for the next
five years before having another
exercise
particular domain
I think my answer to your question is
yes
that that's to say if every five years
we exercised for the impact
of an unknown but ghastly virus or
bacterial agent
and we we did it properly and we learned
the lessons in the sense not of writing
great volumes about it but actually
getting down to the business of
correcting the things that had emerged
as not in place
um that would be pretty good that would
be much better than we're likely to do
at the moment uh but if you had for each
domain one exercise every five years
you'd be having
um an exercise every well depends how
many domains you create but at least
every year more frequently than I'm
recommending in other words my two years
suggested that for a particular domain
you probably wouldn't have a repeat for
10 years because you want to deal with
the impact of virus you want to deal
with major impacts on two or three
different elements of our critical
National infrastructure you'd want to
deal with major events of flooding you
know there are various impacts that you
want to look at and exercise for and so
a regular program
would involve quite a long period
between the time when you did one and
hopefully implemented the
recommendations of it and then go on
with the next one on that same subject
it's just in your statement you suggest
wholesale a whole system emergency
exercises at least two in each
Parliament which we tend to suggest
a greater frequency than once every five
years and of course if it were focused
only on one contingency you would end up
with an exercise in each contingency
every two years but I wasn't suggesting
on one contingency so so across the
board across the board the
there are lots and lots of minor
emergencies I don't think you need to
have whole system exercises about them
there are identifiably
You could argue five You could argue ten
but it's sort of not less than five and
not more than ten major kinds of whole
system emergency that might affect the
UK leaving aside their causes
and if you exercise for each of those
every five years you would end up with
more than two of parliament if you
exercised each of those every 10 years
you would end up with roughly two of
Parliament that was what I was worried
you referred earlier to exercise Alice
and and you suppose that perhaps the
recommendations from exercise Alice have
not been or maybe they had been properly
implemented it was in fact after your
time and a particularly in relation to
Opera exercise signature and exercise
signals
through recommendations and the actions
which flow from an exercise
appear to a very large extent to be left
to the government of the day to give
effect to to the ministers to the civil
servants
and and of course they're not all
automatically
put into place
is there an argument that there needs to
be a fresh a new process
by which we may be assured
that all lessons and recommendations
which by
by necessary implication are sensible
ones from an exercise which challenges
the country's emergency response systems
are put into place and are seen to be
put into place abundantly yes I I some
of this is ground we've covered in the
sense that one of the things you need is
for in my view an external red team in a
resilience Institute that would be
keeping track
of whether these things had been done
and simply couldn't be stopped from
doing so
the second thing we haven't covered but
is covered in the government's
resilience framework and is also in the
man Alexander report and various other
documents uh which is that there ought
to be regular reporting to Parliament uh
that can't be evaded uh not because the
Parliamentary debate in itself will shed
much light but because the duty to
report to Parliament will cause the
whole system to worry about whether it
has actually implemented these things
but the third element We have dealt on
uh dealt with which is that there needs
to be a sufficient a sufficiently
well-armed body inside government or as
a separate agency one or the other which
pursues these questions remorselessly
and at a high level and brings to the
attention of the Prime Minister and if
there is one the minister of resilience
if there are things which were
the product of a particular report
of a particular exercise which have not
been implemented if you have that
you have that triple architecture
I think you would stand a very good
chance that most of the stuff would be
implemented pretty well
are you moving to a different topic or
the same one I was going to conclude
with one final topic a very short one my
lady
whichever you prefer shall I continue
and then concluded
um it's obvious
that resourcing
is the most difficult
subject and and one that is of course
highly politicized
and and it forms no
function of this inquiry of course to to
advise or direct that anything be done
in terms of resources resources are a
matter of fact and funding levels are a
matter of different fight
there would appear to be
a problem therefore in so far as
um
decisions about future funding and
future resources
have to be left to the politicians to
decide
but would the creation of this new
architecture to which you refer a new
resilience Institute
be able to at least address in part
that problem
because it could make recommendations as
to how money should be spent
and therefore that would give the
politicians the ability to be able to to
more transparently and more openly make
the decisions about future resources
absolutely I see that as one of the
major roles of the resilience Institute
um
it's extremely important to realize that
most of the steps that really most need
to be taken to improve residence in most
Fields do not cost very much
um uh the the problem has not been that
there wasn't money available to
stockpile PPE or that uh uh we couldn't
have afforded to have a scale-up process
for uh testing uh these are minuscule
amounts in the context of 150 billion
pounds a year of health spending one can
argue until the cows come have about
whether it was or wasn't a good thing to
constrain government expenditure and put
the finances back in order I would argue
it was others would argue it wasn't
should we not go there exactly leave
that Holy aside under any dispensation
that's remotely plausible to the United
Kingdom we can afford to do perfectly
easily all of the things that would most
protect us against the biggest impacts
of these major whole system of agencies
uh for tiny amounts of money the problem
is identifying what they are and forcing
the money to be spent when the Pac and
public opinion and the media and so on
are all too likely to say the money's
been wasted you've been holding the
stockpile for the last 15 years we
haven't had an emergency what are you
doing and then it doesn't matter whether
it costs 50 pounds or 50 billion pounds
because they all sound the same and
there it's a waste it's a scandal we
have to change the culture
so that it's accepted that consciously
spending money that we hope will never
be used
is a good thing to do if in an emergency
it would save us a huge amount of effect
on human beings in our economy and that
change of culture is what I hope for the
resilience Institute could begin to
achieve the reports to Parliament could
begin to achieve the fact of having uh
uh the uh the resilience
head sitting right next to the Prime
Minister would begin to achieve it once
you accept that this is a fundamental
feature of government and well worth
spending a little bit of money on then
you've changed the culture and much will
follow
does that analysis apply equally to the
fields of Public Health Improvement
which I think it's gender accepted is a
far more expensive
matter than
the the narrow area of emergency
preparedness because in the
context of a pandemic
a Health crisis
a more resilient
Public Health structure
is obviously desirable but is itself
perhaps very much more expensive I don't
think that most of the things that are
most important in that domain are very
expensive either by comparison with the
vast sums under any dispensation we're
going to be spending on health
um it's typically much much cheaper to
prevent things whether in the health
domain or any other energies to deal
with the after effects we've just spent
I don't know what it is 300 with the
inquiry will probably find out 350 450
billion pounds on the effects of covid
talking about minuscule amounts by
comparison with that and it's well worth
investing in advance
sort of a thinking two short questions
for me sort of
um you was you seem to be disparaging
about the
um lead government Department model
it's inevitable that
the expertise on
transport will lie in the department for
transport and health in the department
of health and so on I don't in that
sense I don't decry the idea that when
we have relatively minor problems I
found myself for example at one stage
involved in
uh well it's not trivial for the people
involved it was not a large-scale
disaster of individuals who were trapped
the other side of the channel or you
know further afield because an airline
was collapsing and they couldn't get
home which is a minor emergency
uh the Department of Transport was
perfectly well equipped to deal with it
they knew what they were doing I sat
with them uh but it was not necessary to
convoke some great
cross-governmental arrangement
um so the idea that that those kinds of
risks should be handled by individual
departments I think is perfectly
sensible there are as I say not causes
but impacts that are so big
that they are definitely rightly
described as whole of system you know
them when you see them
and we could list them
and for those I think the idea that one
Department
is in charge
is mad because they're not going to be
in charge when you get to the response
the the the system we were operating
already meant that they were not in
charge and it would not have been in
charge in the response because in
response we would have gathered in Cobra
we would have been chaired by the Prime
Minister we would have and I think the
incident of the EXO and Xs
uh committees that Michael gave
established uh originally to deal with
brexit to my mind the only advantage of
brexit for covid uh uh were useful what
would be useful in handling uh any
future cross-gotten uh whole of system
emergency so
it's very clear to me that you can't
describe these major risks whole system
risks as owned by a department and and
and therefore they need to be attended
to by a central entity that keeps its
focus on that and and learns
continuously and has any corporate
existence
thank you um the other question I had
was that she mentioned support for the
um
idea from
man Alexander about Regional tears of
resilience for
um I'm no lover of bureaucracy as you
may have gathered from some things I've
said um sort of a bit
if you have a regional there why aren't
you just imposing yet another structure
somebody's got to manage the structure
called the meetings had all the minutes
why doesn't it become an unnecessary
layer of bureaucracy on top of what is
already quite a complex system
well it could do
um but um
perhaps it would help if I Illustrated
this not from my
um cabinet office
experience but from my experience as a
local MP in West Dorset
um uh the
the the the
lrf that local residents Forum endorse
it
is composed of uh people from Dorset
County Council police
um
and you know if there's a problem at the
Village of Biddle Hinton this is fine
but if there's a widespread problem
around
um shall we say the flooding of the
Southwest as as unfortunately happens
reasonably frequently
um uh first of all the ambulance service
is not organized on there County basis
it's organized on a regional basis
uh secondly Rivers inconveniently Don't
Follow County boundaries so if you want
to manage them you've got to manage
upstream and downstream and you have
several counties involved
I I I'd be tedious to go on enumerating
there are I get the point various
respects in which for mid-level crises
Regional coordination is necessary it's
then just a question of whether you set
it up ad hoc which is what happens at
the moment or whether you have it there
permanently my argument for having it
there in a small I mean I'm talking
about five people or something but a
small group of people uh being there
permanently is that then as well as
bringing together the relevant people to
handle emergency when it arises they
could be involved in the planning in
advance and so when they got to the
emergency they'd know about it
the coordination
thank you very much well um I think
that's all the questions there are no
real 10-4 questions
you've been extremely helpful and been
very interesting Sullivan thank you very
much
I shall return at 22 12.
all right
my lady may I call George Osborne please
would you like to take the oath
God
I swear by almighty God that the
evidence I should give for the evidence
I should give shall be the truth shall
be the truth the whole truth nothing but
the truth
is your full name George Gideon Oliver
Osborne uh yes it is thank you
thank you students that you've given to
the inquiry thus far Mr Osborne
provision of your witness statement and
also documents and thank you for coming
to give evidence to the inquiry today
please keep your voice up and speak into
the microphones so that the stenographer
can hear you for the transcript
um you were Shadow Chancellor from 2005
to 2010 then Chancellor of the ax
Checker from 2010 to 2016 and first
secretary of state from May 2015 to July
2016. your witness statement is at
inq000187308 uh it's on screen now
please can you confirm that that is your
witness statement and that it's true to
the best of your knowledge and belief uh
yes it is thank you my lady may we have
permission to publish it thank you we
can take that down before we start Mr
Osborne I understand that you want to
say a few words well I just wanted to
express my heartfelt sympathy to all
those who lost a loved one during the
pandemic and for those who feel things
could have been done differently out of
the inquiry gets to the bottom of what
those things might have been thank you
I'm going to ask you questions about
whether or not the treasury had a plan
for a pandemic and if so what that was
and how the treasury contributed to the
government's planning for a pandemic I
emphasize from the outset that this
examination is not a discussion or a
debate about the merits or otherwise of
the government's fiscal policy or indeed
the imposition of austerity we will
touch upon the effects of a sustained
period of austerity in the United
Kingdom but only in so far as it relates
to the state of the country's
preparedness and resilience when covert
hit
in order to put your evidence in context
Mr Osborne the treasury is the
government's economic and finance
ministry it maintains control over
public spending and sets the direction
of the United Kingdom's economic policy
and as Chancellor you were the minister
of the government in charge of the
treasury there are other important
entities in the financial architecture
that we will touch upon including the
office for Budget responsibility which
you set up during your tenure as
Chancellor
and in your witness statement at
paragraph 7 to 11 we don't need to look
at it I'm going to attempt to summarize
it when you came to power immediately
after the 2008 financial crisis you
imposed an economic policy
intended to improve the United Kingdom
public finances and meaning that the
United Kingdom was in better Financial
shape to face the pandemic when it hit
you
say in your statement that your handling
of the treasury allowed the government
to fund for the furlough scheme and the
bounce back loan scheme and other
pandemic Fallout
that you made reforms to financial
services which meant that there wasn't a
banking crisis as a result of the covid
um pandemic and that you invested in
research and development importantly
vaccine development which was important
when covid hit is that a first summary
of your explanation as you give it in
your witness statement of the policy
that you implemented uh yes it is thank
you
so that gives us an understanding of how
you believe the Treasury under your
watch contributed to the government's
preparedness for a pandemic but I want
to explore with you the plan that the
treasury had for a pandemic you say at
paragraph 16 in your witness statement
that for the risks where the treasury is
allocated as a lead Department it
develops scenarios and determines the
potential impact and likelihood of the
risk in question
that was the case prior to at the
covid-19 pandemic so does it follow Mr
Osborne that where the treasury treasury
was not the lead government Department
it didn't develop such scenarios
uh basically yes uh so if I'm at library
I mean there are certain crises which
the treasury is clearly directly
responsible as a banking banking crisis
uh an economic crisis a run on the pound
sadly our country has experienced many
of these over the decades
um and the treasury is clearly the lead
Department to pick up on the
conversation that you've just been
having with Oliver letman yes for those
crises
um but when it comes to other kinds of
crises that might affect our government
the treasury is is a contributor to the
whole of government plan that usually
another department leads in the case of
pandemics the Department of Health the
Department of Health yes so we'll look
in a moment at how the treasury assisted
the Department of Health being the lead
government department for pandemic
preparedness but before we do could we
please display on the screen page eight
paragraph 20 of your witness statement
and we through it together please
you say here between 2010 and 2016 Her
Majesty's Treasury and therefore the
chancellor contributed to
cross-government preparations for civil
emergencies this contribution broadly
fell into four categories a the
monitoring assessing and managing of
Economic and fiscal risks
B leading responsibility in government
for monitoring and responding to risks
to the stable operation of the UK
Financial system learning the lessons of
the financial crisis
C setting budgets and applying spending
controls and or conditions for
government departments although noting
that it was ultimately for the relevant
Secretary of State to decide how to
allocate their budgets and D preparing
Her Majesty's treasury's own corporate
structures to enable effective crisis
management working closely with the
permanent secretary and other senior
officials again learning from the
financial crisis
so summarizing those four points
you believed that the treasury's job was
to plan for economic and fiscal risks a
stable operation of the United Kingdom
Financial system at setting the budgets
and applying spending controls and also
preparing the treasury's own corporate
structures to enable effective crisis
management
that's right yes
whilst this may well be a form of
pandemic planning these are all purely
economic risks and matters which fall
directly under the treasures remit in
any event these are the treasury acting
on business as usual aren't they well
the only thing I would draw attention to
is that most
um whole country crises of which a
pandemic is an obvious example but uh
you know a devastating military attack
uh you know catastrophic
um civil emergency of some kind would
probably lead to a second crisis which
is an economic or financial one and
indeed in the spring of 2020 you know I
wasn't in government but it was clear
for everyone observing government that
they were not only dealing with a health
emergency but they were dealing with a
economic emergency and a financial
emergency and a huge amount of effort
successful as it turns out was put into
trying to stabilize them markets make
sure the banking system didn't fall over
um and so I think you know it's quite
hard to think of
you know crises on the scale of covid
that would not also have the potential
to tip into a fiscal crisis and or a
financial crisis fiscal being about the
ability of the government to fund itself
Financial being about the ability of the
banking system to cope with the crisis
so I think I'm I'm you know unlike other
things which you might look at the you
know most major civil crises
have the potential to tip into an
economic and financial crisis all right
but but given how Central the treasury
is to the functioning of the United
Kingdom and its economy do you agree
that there appears to have been no
planning for external shocks which would
have a major economic impact in other
words no specific pandemic planning no
plan in the treasury well you know I've
been following the um evidence given to
this inquiry with interest and before
repairing here and you have covered this
territory I'm happy to cover it myself
but clearly you know the UK as indeed I
think is the case of most western
democracies at the time has an influenza
plan and the treasury had done some work
on what the impact of that would be and
it's a hit to GDP there's an expected
period when much of the workforce might
be absent from work for a week or two
uh and there's uh you know tragically in
that case there will be a high mortality
rate
the treasury basically had the
structures to deal with that because
they're already sickness benefits
they're already structures available for
companies to pay people who are not
working who have the flu and in the
exercises that have been done before I
came to office there were some very
specific supply chain issues that have
been established if there if there was
an influenza pandemic around things like
the impact on the Travel industry and
that the like
given what subsequently happened very
small scale yes you're absolutely right
that there was no planning done there by
the UK treasury or indeed as fundament
where any Western treasury
for asking the entire population to stay
at home for months and months on end
essentially depriving large sectors of
the economy like Hospitality of all
their customers for months and months to
come that could have been done couldn't
it well you're completely right that if
someone had said and I know that's
absolutely Accord to what this module
inquiry is looking at if someone had
said
you the UK government should be
preparing for a lockdown that might last
for months then I've absolutely no doubt
the treasury would have developed the
schemes that it did subsequently develop
around the furlough uh the covert loans
and the like what I would say you know
in defense of the officials I work with
who were some of the most hard-working
and dedicated public servants I've ever
come across is that in 2020 it turned
out to be fairly easy and Rapid to be
able to put those support systems in
place not all the other areas we're
gonna I'm sure cover around around the
Health Service but the actual economic
support schemes like furlough were
designed by hard-working treasury
officials in under a pressure situation
very quickly and put in place so yes
planning could have been done for a
photo scheme in advance
I'm not clear observing it as at that
point just a citizen I'm not clear that
that would have made a better furlough
scheme than the one we actually uh as a
country saw all right well well
taking other examples than lockdown and
furlough
um
using for instance a plan to
[Music]
consider the economic
output required for self-isolation or
the covid business Interruption loans or
any
economic effect of a mitigation action
and not none of that was done that there
could have been planning joined up
planning between the Department of
Health identifying what the mitigation
actions were being considered and the
treasury then coming in and dealing with
a worst case scenario a middle case
scenario and assessing whether or not
the proposed mitigation actions were
economically worthwhile none of that
sort of planning took place did it well
you're right that there was no planning
in Britain or indeed as far as nowhere
in France Germany United States
well yeah but it's important because I
think you feel challenging uh you know
the phrases come up here group thing you
know it was not a group thing unique to
this country it there was no assumption
that you would ask the population to
stay at home or ask sorry for the
Mandate at the population stay at home
for months and months on end and what
that and so there was no uh planning
for the for a lockdown
um whose fault was it that there was no
price I don't think that could well I
don't I I don't think it's particularly
fair to sort of a portion blame because
you know the entire scientific medical
community
um again you know hard-working
individuals with the best of intentions
you know we're not we're not
elevating this particular possibility
of a coronavirus that would have this
level of contagion that have
asymptomatic patience uh and you know
the treasury or indeed the education
department or the criminal justice
system should pay attention and come up
with some plans for if that was to
happen if we had I mean I think you know
sorry to
you know if you look at the plan then
the planning for the influenza pandemic
and of course we don't know in practice
with they have to come into contact with
reality
how it would have fared but it's clear
that the treasury energy the rest of
government responds to reasonable
requests by saying yes you know please
stock
um antivirals yes like please uh have in
place Advanced vaccine uh have an
advanced vaccine purchasing agreements
yes let's have some money set aside for
call centers we can set up but that is
digging down with the Department of
Health and working out whether or not
there would be such a catastrophic if
effect to a lockdown that it would have
to be considered and the benefit of of
considering that prior to the incident
hitting is you're not making these
decisions on the hoof what I would what
I would observe now just as a you know
citizen who very much wants this inquiry
to come up with some good answers is I
don't think we still know the answer to
some of those questions you know I don't
want to jump ahead for this inquiry but
you know should the schools have been
locked down in the way they were like
even now after the inquiry after the
pandemic we don't know the answer to
those questions well certainly I don't
and maybe the inquiry can get to the
bottom of that they're certainly worth
asking but you know they are absolutely
absolutely critical questions about
balancing you know the life expectancy
of an 80 year old versus the educational
opportunities of an eight-year-old
incredibly hard questions and it's not
absolutely clear to me now that as a
country we know all the rest of us knows
what the answer to those things is so I
think it it's you know it took the idea
that all of this could have been sort of
forethought
uh I don't think it's the case what I
think is certainly the case is that if
the you know if the expert community
and governments had anticipated that
there could be a pandemic that was not
an influencer but was a another form of
respiratory disease and had
characteristics that weren't like
influenzas like asymptomatic patients
and so on then clearly we could have
done certain things which hopefully is
I'm sure this query will get around to
recommending to prepare for those things
in advance like stockpiling more PPE but
I've absolutely no doubt that as
Chancellor and indeed any of the
chancellors before me all substant good
to me if they've been asked to provide a
budget for stockpiling PPE 10 20 30
million pounds whatever it would have
been as as Oliver was pointing out these
are very small sums in the overall
scheme of the government budget and I'm
pretty certain like we said yes to
everything we were asked to fund with an
influenza pandemic we would have said
yes to those things too
should the
those say yes but
I mean the one I would say the one thing
a treasury can do and I think it's a
very powerful statement from the chair
of the obr in your in the witness
evidence that I was shown is you know he
says Richard Hughes in the absence of
perfect foresight fiscal space may be
the most valuable risk tool above all is
a country whatever hits you you need to
be able to respond to throw in this case
large amounts of public funds at the
problem without it leading to the thing
I mentioned earlier the fiscal crisis or
the banking crisis that makes either the
situation very much worse or indeed just
removes the option of funding I mean
poorer countries in the world were not
able to afford lockdowns poorer
countries in the world were not able to
provide loans for businesses to stay in
operation uh so you know this is not
some academic question and indeed in our
own country in the last 12 months we saw
in the Autumn of last year
with the the funding crisis for
government debt that this is not some
abstract problem for the UK either you
know if you can't if you can't fund
yourself you cannot spend 340 billion
pounds on
covet support well you're going back
with respect to the to the issue of
funding the questions were based around
the lack of preparation and the lack of
planning you've you've right yeah just
so sorry I would say that part of
preparation plan is as an economy to
have flexibility to deal with whatever
the world's going through but that's
only part of it isn't it and even
recognizing the questions that need to
be asked it is not a plan it once those
questions have been identified there
then has to be planning for the
practicalities of what might take place
I just want to go to this statement of
Richard Hughes please as you as you
mention him he's the chair of the office
of budget responsibility as you say his
statement is at page
inq000130270 and if we could go to page
five please and look at paragraph
6D of of the witness statement
and whilst whilst we're waiting for that
to be put up on the screen you will be
aware of the evidence that Mr Cameron
gave to the inquiry yesterday that in
his View and indeed since he was
instrumental in bringing into being the
National Security committee and with the
um security advisor and supporting it
um he believed that only a whole
cross-government response to a pandemic
and to these huge catastrophic risks was
was suitable and was going to work
um do you agree Mr Osborne that unless
the treasury is is involved in proper
joined up thinking with the other lead
government departments then there is a
piece of the jigsaw missing and it is
not a cross-government response yes I do
agree with that and I mean
institutionally the treasury is involved
in every government decision because
decisions can't come to the cabinet for
example until the treasury is given its
sign off so the treasury uniquely among
the government departments is already
in the weeds of many many decisions
across government but obviously the
nature of that involvement and the
nature of the cooperation is incredibly
important and you know I listened with
great interest to what my former
colleague Oliver letman was saying or
I'd make one observation to the inquiry
unfortunately not all ministers are like
Oliver let win with the kind of
self-starting capacity to check
everything and Chase everything and you
can't build an entire system
unfortunately around a future supply of
Oliver let wind no
that's a shame
it is um
looking at the document that we've got
on screen then this is just to remind
ourselves from Richard Hughes the chair
of the office for Budget responsibility
and he says this while it may be
difficult to predict when catastrophic
risks will materialize it is possible to
anticipate their broad effects if they
do the risk of a global pandemic was at
the top of government risk registers for
a decade before coronavirus arrived but
attracted relatively little and in
hindsight far too little attention from
the economic community
I'm going to pause there do you agree
with that statement uh yes I do with uh
um but he as he points out with
hindsight
um it's not just the economic Community
obviously that doesn't give sufficient
attention to the you know the
possibility of a coronavirus pandemic
it's it's all sorts of other communities
including the the Health Community yes
um so
um I think there is a you know I I
your line of questioning is completely
correct to because it in my view you're
trying to get to the point which is I'm
sorry I shouldn't be anticipate you're
saying why didn't we plan for a lockdown
why didn't right and the truth is we
didn't plan for a lockdown no treasury
did before me after me no treasuries I'm
probably aware in the rest of the
Western World
um the influenza pandemic was not going
did not pose the same economic planning
challenges that coronavis Rice
subsequently did because in an influenza
pandemic
um lots of people get sick there's you
know tragically a mortality rate and you
have to deal with that but people are
off work for one week and then they come
back to work they're not off work for
months and months and months or not an
offer but absent from the workplace for
months and months and months you're not
there are not whole sectors of the
economy like airlines that don't have
anyone flying on them or restaurants or
pubs they don't have anyone visiting
them so and there's clearly a difference
so it's a massive difference so I think
I think you know on the influenza
pandemic planning the treasury I mean it
was actually the work was done before I
arrived in office by the previous
government but they had made an estimate
that it would hit the economy around
three percent of GDP they've made
necessary about how many people would be
sick over a six-month period they had
done some planning to make sure and
indeed during my period office there was
planning to make sure that the banking
system and the financial system could
cope with the expected absenteeism
of people having flu at home yes
it's completely different to what
actually happened in 2020 2021 where for
months and months on end no one was at
work no but if the analysis no one was
the work at the workplace I should yeah
actually people were working remotely if
if the analysis that you've just
performed in the witness box had been
undertaken prior to covid hitting then
the treasury would not have been Flying
Blind in having to make the decisions
and give the advice that they did why
did that not happen well because no one
in no one said to us I've said this
actually in my um witness statement with
you know no one said to us
there could be a panda a health pandemic
that is not influenza which could which
for which the likely responses you're
going to have to shut down the economy
for months and months on end so that was
not elevated to us as a health risk and
obviously the treasury is not trying to
second-guess although you know Health
experts and this is not I'm not
disparaging the health experts who I
work with very closely in government
it's just it doesn't seem to me and in
all the documentation I've read
everything I've seen in the rest of much
of the world that anywhere else in the
world people are saying you've got to
prepare for this thing and obviously the
entire world is is caught out by what
has happened and indeed I don't actually
it's an interesting question which is
only entirely sort of unknowable would
we all have gone into lockdown if China
had not locked down in January or
February I think the Chinese lockdown is
what gives the rest of the world the
idea of a lockdown and it's the
overwhelming of the hospital system in
Northern Italy that then leads all
Western governments to reach basically
the same conclusion which is we've got
to do that what the Chinese have done in
order to try and preserve our capacity
in our emergency Wards
um and I wonder but it's unnerable that
if we've done a kind of tabletop
exercise in 2011 2012 yes that we would
have come to the conclusion you could
lock down the entire population uh that
whether that would have even been a
feasible policy option as it turned out
to be we'll never know because it was
never done was it
um we asked the treasury to provide us
with
um any plans pandemic plans and evidence
of of what in fact was done uh in the
time that you were Chancellor and
Catherine little who is the treasurer's
second permanent secretary has provided
a witness statement which I know you
will have read Mr Osborne and in it she
says that because the treasury doesn't
hold direct responsibility for pandemic
preparedness that is
um at the door of the Department of
Health we should ask them for any
pandemic preparations
um and to see whether they have any
records of any pandemic preparations
including at the treasury so we have
been provided with plans such as they
existed and they are appended to
Catherine Little's statement the ones
that remain with the treasury and the
only material which the inquiry has been
furnished with post 2010 is a project to
fund a call center and purchase
antibiotics both in 2012 and requests
dealing with the funding of the pandemic
flu clinical countermeasure tummy flu
other than those held within the
treasury there are no plans no reaction
to any of the Department of Health
mitigation proposals and and nothing
specifically relating to any pandemic
threat do you accept that well I what I
would accept is that
um
the items you cite are examples of of to
my knowledge
a hundred percent of the requests made
of the treasury
to fund things that would help deal with
a influenza pandemic are funded and you
gave the examples there there is also a
whole set of planning that goes on
during this period
to deal with banking crises an endless
uh you know exercises which I took part
in and structures with us in the Bank of
England and the Prudential regulator but
we're talking about pandemic planning no
but that was so pandemic I think you
know that would have been part of the
thinking which is if there's a crisis
you know can the banking system cope
um but there's not you know we've well I
don't want to repeat myself there's
certainly there is not planning for a
coronavirus pandemic
should there have been a a plan a
blueprint some sort of Playbook from the
treasury containing strategies and plans
that could have been turned to and
considered when something like the
pandemic occurred well with hindsight
yes but as I've said I question whether
in 2011 2012 2013 if someone had come to
us and said right there's going to be a
coronavirus pandemic and we're going to
ask the whole population to stay indoors
for three months
I wonder in 2011 12 13 whether anyone
would have thought that was a a
plausible plan I mean it turned out to
be one but yeah after partly parts of
the other parts of London started doing
it
if there had been a series of papers
um a series of levels of consideration
given to different scenarios
um dealing with different assumptions so
whether what was coming down the line
might be symptomatic or asymptomatic how
quickly it was likely to reproduce as a
disease then in advance of covid hitting
you would know as Chancellor which
economic leavers would need to be pulled
and how best the treasury could support
the mitigation actions of the Department
of Health and the the problem with not
having that thinking taken place
uh some time before the pandemic hits is
that as I've said before the the result
of that is the treasure is acting on the
hoof well I I don't think that's
entirely fair so first of all you know
the treasury is by its nature it's not a
big delivery department it has around a
thousand individuals who are you know
exceptionally capable uh civil servants
who can deploy their talents and
abilities to different policy problems
as the world throws them you know in the
last two years they've suddenly had to
deal with the Ukraine and energy
supplies and the way that treasury would
not have had a big standing capability
to do with the four but that's one of
the great strengths of the British
treasury
um there are definitely you know
following your line of questioning
things that we could have done yeah if
this kind of threat of a coronavirus
pandemic had been identified in advance
so we could have I'm making sort of you
know sort of I think straightforward
observations like we could have
stockpiled more PPE because we wouldn't
have we would have might have
anticipated that the whole world would
want to get hold of this material and it
was only being produced in a certain
number of factories on the other side of
the world and the US government was you
know doing everything to get hold of it
and so we could have stopped part more
of that
um you know for example we could have
maybe looked at things like having more
respirators in hospitals than we would
normally carry in the health that was
not identified as a particular need I I
think the um you know the sort of
broader question of I I don't want to
repeat myself you know would we have
anticipated the lockdown I I just don't
know the answer to that I all I know is
that when it came when the actual debate
came in March 2020 there was a lot of
uncertainty in our own country about
whether it was the right policy response
and whether the population would accept
it as a policy response so I wonder 10
years in advance whether we you know
would have resolved those questions the
one thing I'm sure of is you know
there's no point having a contingency
plan you can't pay for and at absolutely
Central to all of this is the ability of
your economy and your public finances to
flex in a crisis
the obr
uh mentioned it a few moments ago it is
an organization that that you
implemented during your time in office
and part of the assistance that it gives
to the treasury is the uh preparation
and presentation of fiscal risk reports
can you explain to us what those are
please well these were um so the obr was
created very shortly after I came to
office it gave an independent assessment
of the public finances and it's not just
I think it's important for people to
understand it's not just another think
tank with a sort of another set of
finances sorry another set of forecasts
these are the government's forecasts
there's not some other set of government
forecasts in other words the forecasts
for GDP for unemployment for tax
revenues and so on are independently
produced but they are the official
government forecasts and that is the
central role of the obr and to do that
it is privy to secret information in
government so it is privy to the budget
decisions I gave eight budgets it knew
what was in the budget weeks before the
general public did or indeed weeks
before members of the cabinet would know
what was in a budget so it's a very
important institution the harder
government and we sought to add to its
capability by asking it to undertake
essentially assessment of potential
risks to the UK and what impact they
would have fiscal on the Public Finance
well they were they were issues like I
think you know they looked at everything
from a No Deal brexit to climate change
to uh all sorts of you know things that
might you know have an impact on the UK
and what the fiscal consequences of that
would be so the actual crisis was not a
fiscal crisis it was what was going to
be the cost basically of these various
things that they looked at and there
were business as you usual risks as they
defined weren't there and then there
were also one-off events recognized and
reflected in their risk analysis and in
July of 2017
the obr produced as part of its report
this statement on top of the business as
usual risks there could be one-off
events that generate demand for
additional Health spending such as a
large-scale outbreak of disease for
example an influenza pandemic which the
cabinet office considers to represent
the most significant civil emergency
risk long-term systemic cost pressures
could also arise from sources such as an
increase in antimicrobial resistance so
there was some recognition in the risks
that were identified by the obr of that
which is contained in the National risk
register
yes that's right I think I mean I've
left office by this point I think the
obr actually tell us that they had
considered doing the influenza
scenario planning but in fact they
switched their resources to looking at a
No Deal brexit scenario instead right
well my question for you on on this
topic is this
um does it surprise you get given what
I've just read out to know that despite
there being an acknowledgment of the
influenza pandemic being the most
significant emergency risk
identified by the national risk risk
register that it it the pandemic did not
appear as a risk on the fiscal list well
I think you'd have I mean I don't know
if you're taking evidence from the about
oral evidence but I mean they they made
their own decisions about what they
thought were part of their independence
was to make their own decisions about
what they thought they should look at I
imagine the government at the time would
not have wanted them to look at a No
Deal brexit scenario for example so it's
incredible and they're independent and
made those decisions
um so you'd have to ask them that
question all right well
do you accept I appreciate you not in
office anymore but perhaps you will
accept from me and that by July 2021 the
obr had changed its approach to risks
particularly those identified in the
National risk register in two ways
firstly there was a broader focus in its
report of three major risks rather than
97 individual risks and though one of
those three major risks that is now
covered in great detail is is the risk
of a pandemic and secondly there appears
to be much more joined up thinking now
between the risks identified by the obr
the fiscal risks and those identified in
the National risk register
so they have adapted and learned from
what happened during the crisis no
that's absolutely right and they I think
they specifically in that case are
looking at what happens if a coronavirus
strain that the vaccines aren't work
effective against
um so yes absolutely but of course you
know look I would say you know what it
points to is look try and put in place
the right Machinery I you know I I wish
this inquiry you know every success in
trying to anticipate what we could do in
the future for
um different crises but the truth is
we're not going to be able to anticipate
every crisis that hits the United
Kingdom over the rest of our lifetimes
and therefore having uh you know a
strong obr uh you know a treasury with
the capacity to come up with quick
policy making uh central government
Machinery that can respond quickly to
you know that is also important you know
that's also important as well as trying
to anticipate specific crises that you
can specifically plan for can we put up
please the witness statement of Sir Mark
walport which is at
inq00014707 and go to paragraph 86 at
page 33.
and given what you've just said Mr
Osborne about the fact that not every
eventuality can be predicted or planned
for I'd like your view on what uh Sir
Mark says here at paragraph 86.
every National Emergency has knock-on
effects on citizens lives beyond the
immediate impact of the emergency itself
and there is always the possibility that
the cure for this specific emergency in
terms of the policies and actions
directed at stemming the primary damage
causes harmful side effects in the case
of a pandemic lockdowns and quarantining
closing International borders and other
restrictions to travel closing of
Institutions such as schools and
businesses all have serious adverse
consequences this raises important
questions for policy makers about how to
balance the direct harms from the
pandemic infection against the adverse
consequences of interventions singly or
in combination
the
statement highlights does it not the
importance of a department trying its
level best to anticipate not only what's
coming down the line but also what is
going to be the effect of the mitigation
actions that might have to be taken
I mean yeah I mean this you know Mark I
know Mark very well in the work with him
he said this goes to my mind the heart
of the you know very difficult question
that the government of the day had to
wrestle with in any future government to
wrestle with which is you know what is
the what are the what are the costs and
benefits of dealing with the health
problem
the spread of the disease versus the
impact of closing a school I have
school-aged children at the time of the
pandemic uh you know closing the court
system so that people don't get their
trial uh you know
locking down prisoners in prisons uh you
know all sorts of other things that
um you know had a really damaging impact
and the you know these you go to the
heart are very difficult societal
questions of which frankly I don't you
know you can produce any amount of
economic analysis of what's the you know
benefit of
you know controlling coronavirus for a
day and shutting a school for a day
but I I think in the end they come down
to essentially kind of human societal
judgments of what are the things we
value and the truth is
you know different human beings will
value different things some people will
say the education of the child is more
important than you know protecting older
patients in our you know Care Homes but
that
that I mean ultimately we have
democratic governments that are
accountable to the general public in
order to try and make those very
difficult decisions if this inquiry can
help any future government I you know if
I'm not sure I'm a lady if I'm allowed
to say this but I personally think of
this your inquiry which I strongly
support if you can come if you can give
some kind of guidance
to answering that question it is the
single most useful thing this inquiry
can do for any future government which
will be faced with very difficult
questions uh like the government was
faced in 2020. are you suggesting Mr
Osborne in the answer that you've just
given that it was not worth the treasury
attempting to to engage in any
significant planning will cause the
decisions have to be made when the when
the pandemic hits no I'm I'm the
treasury did not engage in the planning
because no one had anticipated that you
would have to or you would have the
option of or it would be something you
should consider locking down the economy
in order to deal with an asymptomatic
non-influenza which is a spiritual
pandemic an Arts you've already given
and may I suggest that had the treasury
been interested in engaging in
pre-pandemic planning then it would have
taken a bigger part in the two exercises
that took place during your tenure and
just after you'd left looking at the
reports into exercise Alice that took
place in February of 2016 and indeed was
an exercise dealing with the outbreak of
a coronavirus the treasury wasn't even
present in exercise cygnus which was
delivered shortly after you left office
but as we know from yesterday planning
for which commenced in 2014 although the
treasury is recorded as being present at
that exercise there is no evidence
whatsoever of any participation or of
any evidence of any lessons to be
learned is that the sort of action that
the treasury could have taken in order
to engage itself with these important
exercises looking at what the result and
the reaction of the government would be
in the outbreak of these sorts of
diseases
this is territory that inquiry has
covered and we've covered a bit in the
evidence I think the treasury was very
engaged in drawing up an influenza
pandemic plan I think those exercises
were kind of operational exercises in
how that plan might actually be put into
practice in hospitals and other
you know facilities
um in which there wouldn't be a sort of
particular role at that moment for a
treasury policy maker the treasury being
as I say a department of policy makers
rather than the delivery department so
it wouldn't have been directly affected
by what the delivery services of
government had to do in a influenza
pandemic
um
you know and there was a general the
treasury had signed off and did I had
signed off
um on the 2011 influenza plan in which
the treasury had as you can see from the
material
um in 2009 had assessed the uh economic
costs had identified a couple of
specific issues but essentially was you
know said okay it's a three percent hit
to GDP but we're not we're not going to
have widespread sectoral impacts which
we need to think of or we're not going
to have to design some system to pay
people to work from home right do you
agree Mr Osborne that by the time that
covid-19 hit the consequences of
austerity were a depleted Health and
Social care capacity and Rising
inequality in the United Kingdom
most certainly not I completely reject
that
um I've made two points the first of all
it's not surprising that the biggest
economic crash that Britain experienced
since the 1930s has an impact on Britain
and on poverty and on unemployment and
on people's life chances
it's unfortunate what happens when your
country experiences such a massive
economic shock as we experienced in 2008
nine the What flows from that is a whole
set of things and one of them is
seriously impaired public finances which
you then have to repair and that is what
we set about doing I would say if we had
not done that Britain would have been
more exposed not just to Future things
like the coronavirus pandemic but indeed
to the fiscal crisis which very rapidly
followed in countries across Europe such
as Spain Italy Greece Ireland Slovenia
all across the continent and in within
one point there was a question mark over
whether France itself would experience a
fiscal crisis so all across the
continent other countries are
experiencing problems of being unable to
fund themselves on the international
debt markets and as I point out in the
Autumn of last year Britain went through
this briefly for a couple of weeks so
this is not some kind of academic
problem that doesn't materialize it's a
very real problem and if we had not had
a clear plan to put the public finances
on a sustainable path then Britain might
have had experienced a fiscal crisis we
would not have had the fiscal space to
deal with the coronavirus pandemic when
it hit seven years later and indeed as
Mr Cameron pointed out yesterday the
example in many of those countries that
did have those crises was there were
real Cuts in health services and other
public services that went far beyond
what the UK experienced or in case in
case the NHS actually budgets went up in
real terms do you agree that during your
time in office the
um
the state of the social care system
became worse
I'm not sure I would accept that I would
certainly accept that there are rising
pressures that including during my
period office on the social care system
all right yeah but they are driven by
the fact Britain has a rapidly aging
population yes
an aging population at a relatively
rapid rate and um that uh you know the
the cost of medical treatments are going
up which is actually generally a good
thing because these are new treatments
that uh can help people but you know the
UK social social care and health system
is experiencing exactly the same kinds
of pressures as the pressures being
experienced in most western democracies
at this moment right well let's look at
the detail please can we have up on
screen inq000189677
now this is a report by The Institute
for government the government Think Tank
whose strap line is inspiring the best
in government and working to make
government more effective this is a
report
that was prepared by the authors sitting
in the bottom left-hand corner it's
headed how fit were public services for
Coronavirus and we don't need to go to
it but just to set this in context this
is a report based on extensive desk
research analysis of government data and
interviews of civil servants Frontline
staff representative bodies and other
experts and
can we go please to page eight of this
report and highlight the final two
paragraphs
and zoom in on those
even before The Crisis began that's the
the covert crisis Public Services had be
had seen reduced access longer waiting
times missed targets Rising public
dissatisfaction and other signs of
declining standards most notably GPS and
hospitals were missing almost all
routine targets whilst prisons had
experienced a dramatic increase in
levels of self-harm violence and poor
prisoner Behavior this context made it
far harder for services to maintain
acceptable standards while also managing
A disruption as wide-ranging and
long-lasting as that wrought by the
coronavirus the response has also been
hampered by historic under-investment in
buildings and Equipment government has
consistently under spent its capital
budgets often using money that had been
earmarked for long-term investment to
cover holes in day-to-day budgets as a
result Public Services have had to
operate out of crumbling prisons court
houses and hospitals that are difficult
to clean or repurpose in line with
coronavirus Health measures and can we
move down to to finish this on the
following page please
the sale of courthouses and police
stations and the failure to build new
prison places have similarly made it
harder to maintain social distancing and
inadequate ICT has reduced the ability
of police officers and local Authority
staff to work from home made it far
harder for prisoners confined in cells
for more than 23 hours a day to access
training or speak to their families and
meant that schools hospitals GPS and
Criminal Courts have all struggled at
times to provide services remotely even
when greatly reduced now there's
reference repeated reference there to
prisons and Court centers and indeed
those will be covered in detail in later
modules so I just want to to focus for
the moment on what the institute for
government have found in terms of the
state of the health public services and
the ability for them to react to
coronavirus it is that picture something
that you recognize
um the short answer is no because by the
time I left office there were more
doctors working in the NHS more nurses
working in the NHS as Mr Cameron pointed
out yesterday diagnostic testing had
increased in the NHS and public
satisfaction had remained broadly
constant during a difficult period for
the economy and for the constraint of
spending in public finances I make a
general observation I mean if you put
all this together
the Health Service the criminal justice
system the education system the social
care system
I think basically you've just left out
defense but if we had some generals here
that no doubt want some more tanks
that is public spending so you can't you
can't just say uh well we'd like public
spending to be higher without then
explaining where you're going to get the
money from I've pointed out the risks of
borrowing the money so you can certainly
go to the general population and say
please will you pay more taxes I would
note the present prime minister just
last year proposed a National Insurance
rise to pay for the NHS and it was
rejected by his own party and by the
opposition so in other words this is the
job of the chance exactly you are going
straight to the part of it which is
you've got to balance all of these
competing demands right so within public
services for different uh different
Services wanting more money
plus the you know constraints on a
country of borrowing the money in
international markets plus the
constraints on the general population
just willing willy-nilly paying more tax
and the way the taxpayer is also a core
participant in that sense to this
inquiry
that you're making Mr Osborne and in
your witness statement you claimed that
the Department of Health funding for the
NHS was Ring fenced or or was increased
in fact year on year during the course
of your time as Chancellor whilst other
departments were reduced by up to 19 yes
right well I'd like to explore that with
you please I would make one point but
also we also please just let me ask my
question of course I'd like to explore
that in terms of social care and in
terms of Public Health because
from the time of the implementation of
the Health and Social Care Act of 2012.
it's right isn't it that um certainly
certain of the public health
responsibilities moved from the National
Health Service over to local authorities
and therefore came outside of the budget
that part of the budget that the
Department of Health would give to the
National Health Service do you agree
with that yes yes so um in terms of of
of whether or not the um the funding for
public health had been ring fenced in
the way in which you describe in your
witness statement what we have to in
fact look at is how the local public
health was being funded through the
local authorities and in order to do
this and to demonstrate my point can we
put up please
inq00205-178 which is the witness
statement of Dr class kashelli
and can we go to page 70 and paragraph
108 I'd like your comment on on this
please once we've read through it Mr
Osborne
functioning functioning of the new local
and National Public Health structures
was compromised by austerity politics at
the local level the abolition of pcts
meant that overall Public Health
performance was strongly dependent on
local Authority capabilities to
commission and deliver effective
Services ministers had promised to ring
fence the public health budget for local
authorities however an in-year cut of
200 million pounds in 2015 was followed
by further reductions over the next five
years according to the local government
Association this amounted to a real-term
reduction of the public health Grant
from over 3.5 billion in 2015 to 16 to
just over 3 billion in 2020 to 21
a loss of 14 other estimates by The
Institute for Public Policy research
spoke of an even more dramatic reduction
from 800 50 million in net expenditure
between 2014-15 and 2019-20 with the
poorest areas in England experiencing
disproportionately High cuts of almost
15 percent resulting pressures on local
public health were exacerbated by an
overall 49 real-term cut in central
government funding for local authorities
between 2010-11 and 2016-17 and a
resulting practice of top slicing
whereby authorities reallocated ring
fenced Public Health budgets to other
services broadly impacting health and
well-being such as trading standards or
parks and green spaces
in 2010 healthy lives healthy people had
promised to give local government the
freedom responsibility and funding to
innovate and develop their own ways of
improving
Public Health in their area freedom and
responsibility had been granted but
funding was often lacking what do you
say about that Mr Osborne
well there are several things I'd say
about this I mean first of all
um I think it's universally accepted
that the decision which was not mine was
taken elsewhere in the government but
the decision to transfer Public Health
from the NHS to local authorities has
turned out to be broadly speaking a good
thing there is no one as far as I'm
aware arguing that it should be returned
to the NHS what about the funding
position well we'll come on to the
funding position but you know the
central because this is uh you know it
also helps address the funding point so
first of all that was an important
decision and amend the public health
decisions were tied in with other
decisions that local government takes
around housing and and the like
licensing Recreation facilities and so
on
second as it happens during the paradise
Chancellor the public health budget went
up the the numbers you refer to are from
2015 to 2020 yes left office shortly
after 2015.
um but I would make a broader point
which is you know here there's a kind of
challenge which is a classic policy
making challenge of to what extent do
you try and ring fence things and say
local authorities must spend this money
on this particular thing indeed public
inquiries of all kinds have generally
led to conclusions that budget should be
ring fenced for the thing the public
inquiry was looking at yes and then over
time a local Authority has less and less
discretion about how to spend money
because this bits are influence that
bits are influenced and so on and UI
eBay a erode local decision making and
local democracy and you also end up with
a whole load of siled individual ring
filters so as a government the camera
and government which I was an active
part was actually promoting localism and
we and indeed we went further in
devolving power such as indeed the NHS
and Public Health and Social Services in
Manchester to the greater Manchester
Authority
well then you then you come to the point
which is and by the way local government
has his own resources it can raise they
all cut local taxes uh as part of the
taxation system is in the hands of local
government but I would make a gonna then
I make the point first of all money's
not the solution to all public health
problems I introduced a sugar tax which
has I believe had a big impact on
reducing sugary drinks and uh helping
with obesity levels in the UK smoking uh
during the Cameron government reduced as
a uh quite dramatically the the amount
of the population proportional
population smoking so you can do all
sorts of other things to help with
public health if you're coming back back
to like the public health budget well
then
then you know that that which straddles
several different parts of government uh
again comes into the general question
you've got of which budgets you're going
to cut or what money you're going to
borrow what taxes you're going to put up
right and we had made a decision to to
ring fence the NHS and indeed to ring
fence some of these Public Health Grants
by the way I might just observe that
public health England which we created
was absolutely instrumental in coming up
I think within three days for a test
with coronavirus so we did put in place
structures that in 2020 did deliver in
the case of developing a very rapid test
which was required for this brand new
disease well I'm going to suggest Mr
Osborne that public health England
failed in its mission to increase the
country's Public Health
you will know that your secretary of
state for health and then Health and
Social care Jeremy Hunt has provided a
witness statement to the inquiry in
which he says that he acknowledges that
during his time as Secretary of State
the NHS required more funding there was
as you have already acknowledged a
rapidly Rising demand for services an
aging population that that he considered
that there were stuffing capacities
within the system that were causing
difficulties and that the NHS Workforce
requirements which have historically
been considered in an ad hoc way need to
be sorted out in order for the National
Health Service to to properly support
the capacity that's required and that
that's the in normal circumstances but
when one takes that into account when
the pandemic hit do you accept his
criticisms that the system was not
working as prop as it should be and that
part of the reason for that must have
been the funding
well I've I've read his evidence which I
thought was very good and had some
interesting and constructive ideas for
the future around uh testing
capabilities and so on
um and lessons to be learned from South
Korea and Taiwan and other countries
um I think from memory he actually
identifies brexit and immigration as one
of the problems that the Health Service
had relied on a stream of people coming
into the country to fill uh posts in
nursing and well you know other parts of
the medical profession and that you know
proved problematic During the period
um he was Health secretary I I had by
then left the government all right do
you agree that
um however
well-funded you say the NHS was during
your time as Chancellor it simply wasn't
enough
no I don't accept that I mean what I
accept is you could spend more money on
the NHS just like you could spend more
money on the court system more money on
the school system more money on the Army
um but you have to make a calculation of
you know balancing the resources each of
those Services get
the and the results and the central
calculation
whichever every household has to make is
what can we actually afford because what
can we what's the revenue that's coming
in
um and so I think you know we
prioritized uh health I would also you
know it's not insignificant there's that
at the 2010 general election this is
exactly what we said we were going to do
cut other areas but increase health very
we went into the general election
telling the public we were going to cut
those other services and in 2015 we also
said the same thing and on both cases
you know the public put their confidence
in us so in terms of also Democratic
accountability I don't think the public
were misled about what the government
would do and the evidence of the 2015
election were prepared to continue to
place their trust in us can we display
one one
three
is the obr's first fiscal risk report
from July of 2017. I've already made
reference to it and can we go to
paragraph 162.
and look at sorry page 162 and look at
paragraphs 6.66 and 6.67
this was the risk report provided a year
after you had left office and if we can
look please at
in fact
6.66 we will start with thank you very
much
it's headed pressures on the adult
social care budget and how government
has responded as with health there are
visible signs of pressure on the adult
social care system in the past two years
governments have announced Top-Up
funding and delayed reforms that would
increase costs further the government
has stated that further reform is
required to ensure that the system is
prepared to meet the challenges of the
increasing numbers of over 75s and that
it will work with Partners at all levels
including those who use services and who
work to provide care to bring forward
proposals for public consultation signs
and sources of pressure on the adult
social care budget include
pressure on local Authority budgets has
fed through to adult social care for
those authorities in England with
responsibility for adult social care it
is their largest item of discretionary
spending local Authority budgets have
been squeezed by cuts to grant funding
and limits on council tax Rises as a
result English local authorities total
net current expenditure fell by 13.3
percent in real terms between 2010 to 11
and 2015-16 within this total spending
on adult social care fell by less but
local authorities spending on it still
fell by 9.1 percent over the same period
including transfers from the NHS
spending on Adult and Children's social
care exceeded local authorities budgets
in 2014-15 and by a bigger margin of
2015 to 16. now this is the organization
that you created telling us here that um
so far as local Authority budgets are
concerned and adult social care is
concerned the picture was not great
well I'm not um I'm not saying I'm sure
it does say that to be honest I mean I
think it points out that there are
pressures on the adult social care
system that's statement of the obvious
in all uh Advanced democracies at the
moment and then it goes to point out
that there were reductions in the local
government budget yes there were we we
announced they're not like secret
reductions in the glaucoma Market they
were publicly announced as part of a
program of trying to reduce government
expenditure but if you exclude uh local
government education defense criminal
justice and the NHS you haven't got
anything left that is what public
expenditure is plus welfare spending
which uh you know people also are not
keen on having reduction reduced so
welfare entitlements so yes there were
reductions in local government budgets
that's because the country had had an
enormous financial crash was poorer than
it had been before was going to be
permanently poorer there was an impact
on it you know it's it's permanent
potential had been impacted by the crash
and we had to try and make sure that
public expenditure fitted the size of
the economy whilst getting the economy
growing and putting people into work and
reducing poverty which all happened
under our as well so we've got the
economy going so that you could afford
to spend ultimately more on those things
I would just say on social care it's
really straightforward there are two
people who can pay for social care the
taxpayer can pay and then you've got to
be prepared for higher levels of General
taxation Rishi soon Acts NHS and social
care Levy was rejected by the
conservative body in the late party in
the last year or you can ask people to
sell their homes
the assets they have to pay for that
social care there's no one else who's
going to pay for it the taxpayer or the
individual and the political system for
20 years on the governments of all
colors have rejected those two options
which is why you continually read that
there's an ongoing uh you know debate
about what the the social care problem
is unsolved that's because the solutions
are currently unpalatable to the
political system which I would suggest
is a reflection of being unpalatable to
the broader taxpayer and Society but
what about the effect of the falling
expenditure you know that last week the
inquiry has heard from professors Marmot
and bambra who told the inquiry that
changes in the social determinants of
health because of austerity since 2010
were likely to be the causes of the
adverse changes in health and health
inequalities in the UK
and also I know that you've had sight of
this statement of Professor Kevin Fenton
the president of the United Kingdom
faculty of Public Health who's told the
inquiry that a key lesson learned
through the pandemic has been the
importance of robust engagement with
potentially disproportionately affected
populations both in the planning and
preparedness
it is firstly that
government policy had an effect on
Health and Social care which meant that
those in the worst situations of society
were disproportionately affected when
covert hit and secondly that that was
identifiable it was predictable and it
should have been part of the government
planning I just completely reject that
and you know in the case of the Marmot
and Bamber report you know and obviously
they there's a lot of very interesting
work on health inequalities which we did
a huge amount to seek to address
they have this statement of paragraph
151 National Economic wealth I.E GDP has
long been considered as the major Global
determinant of population health of
course in other words that's what
Britain had a huge economic crash the
greatest since the 1920s and 30s Great
Depression and of course that it had an
impact on poverty in the country it
would have been worse in my view and in
the view of many other people including
the governor of the bank of England at
the time Mervyn King had we not then
also tried to address the risks to the
public finances because that would have
led to a fiscal crisis like you saw
across much of Europe that would have
meant even less funding for these Public
Services we tried to protect the Health
Service during that austerity program
and I you know Marmot and Bamber
themselves say that they don't they
can't directly establish causality
between austerity and the mortality
rates they look at and the only example
I can find in their report of a country
that they cite that has a stimulus
program is Iceland which by the way is a
population about the size of the borough
that this courthouse is in right and
then even in the same paragraph go on to
point out that Iceland had some severe
health effects from the crisis and they
leave out the United States which was
the primary example of a country in the
west that tried a stimulus program as
opposed to an austerity program because
they say oh yes we're actually mortality
fell there I've even done my own
research and found out the mortality
fell in Germany for the poorest
population part of the population during
the paradise Chancellor and I don't
think anyone thinks that Germany pursued
a particularly tough austerity program
during that period so I just see I just
reject all right and then I just reject
I I would Center on their Central
conclusion which is National Economic
wealth has long been considered as the
major Global terminal population health
so it's your evidence Mr Osborne is that
although you acknowledge that in certain
aspects the effect of covid were felt
more keenly by those most Constitution
society that has no connection
whatsoever to the effects of austerity
that were brought in in 2010. that's
absolutely my contention right it is
true that pandemics will affect poorer
people yes more severely and that is one
of the great tragedies which I was
trying to try and alleviate poverty and
Direct Services towards them I think
everything we did just try and ring
fence the NHS budget to provide stable
finances so that they were not further
affected by a fiscal crisis things like
Universal Credit which reduce all of
these things were done to try and
protect the poorest part of the
population indeed I was the first
Chancellor ever to publish
distributional analysis of the effect of
my policies that budget after budget
precisely to show
that we were trying to direct resources
in constrained times to the poorest and
most vulnerable who are indeed generally
more exposed to things like pandemics
tragically
um how are we doing because I think
when they say Mr Osborne and I share a
tendency which is to speak very fast
and the stenographer I'm afraid has had
a a tough morning so I I only have two
more you think you can finish by one
o'clock yes I will finish by one o'clock
okay can I apologize through you my lady
for talking too quickly for the uh don't
worry I do it too so I'm afraid we're in
the same camp
two final questions please the first
going back to health economics and I'd
like to put to you at the statement made
by Professor sir Chris Whitty in his
witness statement we don't need to put
it up but but he has told the inquiry
this there may be a need to look at
operational issues and the cost
effectiveness of particular
interventions within CMO or Sage advice
so Health economics may be relevant to
the medical and scientific advice this
is because giving advice which is
operationally unfeasible or
substantially disproportionate in cost
or difficulty is not especially helpful
and and that is mirrored and expanded by
the witness statement of professor John
Edmonds from the Department of
infectious disease epidemiology at the
London School of hygiene and tropical
medicine and he says this there needs to
be far greater attention paid to the
economic impact of pandemics and the
interventions aimed at controlling them
oh thank you very much it's on the
screen the economics of outbreaks is a
specialized field interventions can have
major knock-on effects so that
individuals who are not directly reached
or targeted by the intervention can
still benefit as they have a reduced
risk of infection from others these
knock-on effects need to be incorporated
into the analysis to avoid
underestimating the benefits of Public
Health actions just pausing there
do you agree with these two scientific
experts that there needs to be joined up
thinking between the science and the
economy uh yes absolutely I I mean but I
would observe that you know if you're
trying to think through how a future
government might deal with yeah a
pandemic
it's not just the health impacts you
know you have to what I think the
government wrestled with at the time I
wasn't in it but I can see as an
external Observer with my experience was
also the educational impacts the
criminal justice impacts and the like of
of the lockdown
and trying to balance those if you can
apply more and indeed the you know
impact on businesses and you know
people's um
employment if you know trying to get you
can certainly apply more analysis to all
of that
I personally think you're going to end
up with a very different difficult
essentially sort of human Judgment of
are you valuing education over health
um in some cases you know and that is a
very very all and other examples like
that and that's an incredibly hard
trade-off which I guess we have you know
in our country elected governments to
try and make on our behalf all right
thank you finally let's just look at the
consequences of failing to plan and can
we display please inq double zero double
zero eight seven two zero five
and look at paragraph 16 at page four of
the pandemic diseases capabilities Board
review of April 2022
paragraph 16 please
foreign
with the National Security risk
assessment methodology revised pandemic
reasonable worst case scenario models
represent unmitigated scenarios and so
do not include a full risk assessment
for the use of npis non-pharmaceutical
interventions given that the imposition
of lockdown in part accounted for a 25
drop in GDP between February and April
2020 the largest drop on record and
numerous secondary and tertiary impacts
on all sectors this represents a
significant Gap in the UK's assessment
of pandemic risk noting that even
without government intervention we would
anticipate spontaneous Behavior change
in subsequent economic damage what is
more the secondary and tertiary impact
of these measures will have been
unevenly spread throughout Society
highlighting and in areas exacerbating
pre-existing inequalities now can we go
to page five and paragraph 18.
and can we highlight 18 19 and 20 please
the unpre unprecedented use of npis in
significant changes in public Behavior
seen during the covid-19 pandemic
required the provision of far greater
economic support than pre-covered
planning assumptions suggested
the planning assumptions in the 2011 UK
influenza pandemic preparedness strategy
focused on the economic impacts of
sickness absences
as a result the strategy did not include
many of the significant economic impacts
which we have seen during this pandemic
such as the dramatic drops in economic
activity significant shifts and
reductions in consumer spending and
disruption to Global Supply chains the
obr's fiscal risks report from July 2021
which we've looked at suggests the
United Kingdom's real GDP declined by an
unprecedented 9.8 percent in 2020 and as
of September 2021 the Nao estimated the
lifetime cost of government spending on
covid-19 will reach 370 billion clearly
then in line with recommended
recommendation 2.1 are economic risk
assessment for pandemics must be updated
to include a broader range of impacts
including the significant potential
impacts of mpis and behavioral changes
on different sectors of the economy
do you agree with that conclusion Mrs
well I do I absolutely agree with the
conclusion I I'm knowing the brilliant
civil sermons of the treasury I suspect
they've already done it for you they
already will be a load of internal
assessments of the future effect of for
example coronavirus
um variations that don't have vaccines
at the moment that are effective were
they to emerge yes but I would make you
know I would I guess my sort of I I
where we started with this was did the
treasury or indeed any other government
part of government or indeed any other
Western Government anticipate that it
might require a lockdown that would
impact the economy but as it says here
by a drop of 25 GDP no they didn't
but we through the program we pursued as
a government we created the fiscal space
so we could end up spending 370 billion
pounds to help people uh deal with all
the adverse effects that the lockdown
introduced in terms of um their
education their their way the criminal
justice system worked and above all
their employment and we kept people uh
as a country uh economically in a much
better shape than they would have been
if we'd not been able to spend that
money and that's because we created the
fiscal space it meant we avoided the
banking crisis and we did that because
of the reforms that happened during the
period that I was in government and as a
result of the determined effort to fix
the roof I'm sure that in subsequent
modules the inquiry will be told whether
or not these plans are indeed now in
practice but if that's right Mr Osborne
it's a shame that this wasn't done
before isn't it
well I've just pointed out no one I'm
aware of anywhere in the Western World
maybe anywhere else anywhere in the
world said you know what governments
should prepare for they should prepare
for a conversed pandemic that will
require us to lock down the entire
economy for months on end obviously if
someone had said that then there would
be a legitimate question which is why
aren't you preparing for it but I'm
unfortunately no one did and it's as I
say my own evidence uh I I of course
dearly wish they had
my lady that concludes my questioning of
this witness uh there are no rule nine
requests by any other core participant
it's now one o'clock but would you like
to rise please I will indeed um I should
come back at two thank you very much
indeed Mr Osborne and I'm glad we could
complete before lunch thank you
thank you
my lady this afternoon we're hearing
from Professor Dame Sally Davis notably
the former Chief medical officer for
England which in 2010 and 2019
I swear by almighty God
that the evidence I shall give shall be
the truth the whole truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth thank
you
James Hardy could you give the inquiry
please your name
Sally Claire Davis thank you
Dave Sally thank you very much for your
assistance to the inquiry
you've been provided with a great deal
many documents and I know it's a
romantic midnight oil has been burned in
preparation
whilst you give evidence could you
please keep your voice up so that we may
hear your evidence and of course that
the sonographer can hear you for the
transcript if I ask a question which is
not clear please don't hesitate to ask
me to repeat it
you provided help for your witness
statement dated the 4th of May 2023
could we have please one eight four six
three seven
and page 14.
[Applause]
there's the statement of Truth on the
Declaration dated the 4th of May 2023 my
lady could that be published Circle it
Dame Sally
you
were from 2004 to
2016 the chief Scientific Advisor to
what was then known as the Department of
Health but which became the Department
of Health and Social care and also
director general for research in the
Department of Health
you were between June 2010
and 2000 October 2019 the chief medical
officer for England
between 2014 and 2016 you were a member
of the Executive Board of the World
Health Organization
between 2017 and 2020 you were a
co-convener of the United Nations
interagency coordination group on
antimicrobial resistance
and are you currently master of Trinity
College Cambridge
useful for The Inquirer to be aware of
is that as chief medical officer for
England I was also the UK government's
most senior medical advisor
thank you
that is in fact
where I propose to start
could you tell the inquiry please
something about the role of being the
chief medical advisor and being the
chief medical officer
so
Mr Keith the chief medical officer is by
nature a doctor
a leader
appointed as an independent advisor to
government
cross-government and contributing to
cross-government as needed or asked
Cobra Sage which I'm sure we'll talk
about with high security clearance that
was needed during the novichok time
um
I when I started in 2010 I was interim
for one year before I was appointed
through a competitive process
I had no deputy chief medical officers
and no budget for them despite the fact
that my predecessor at one point had had
five deputy chief medical officers and a
broad spam the maximum my office came to
was 13 people including those two dcmos
when I got the money and appointed for
instance I had hunted Jonathan van Tam I
appointed
the present Jennifer Jenny Harris the
present head of UTSA who is both Puma
superb as you know
um
I had a statutory responsibility to
write an annual report on the state of
the nation's Health in whatever way I
chose my predecessor focused on patient
safety and I focused following my first
annual report in 2013 on antimicrobial
resistance AMR which is superbugs that's
the grand ongoing pandemic killing
across the world 1.2 million every year
the third most important on the line
cause of death and so I imagine as we
talk or I expect as we talk about
pandemics I will be able to show you how
difficult it is to raise awareness and
get action even when the deaths are
happening and AMR is a very good example
of that
I had a responsibility to communicate
with CMO often known in inverted Commons
of the nation's Doctor Who saw that
during the pandemic but I played my role
there and of course
no CMO can cover every area and be
expert my background is hematology I'm a
sickle cell disease expert as a matter
of fact
um one of my successor is an
epidemiologist and infectious disease
and my predecessor was straightforward
Public Health with some orthopedic
surgery before and that's why we need
deputy chief medical officers who have
different expertises one in health
Improvement one in health
security or protection
um so that with the office can cover
that span
as CMO for England I was Primus into
Paris with the other chief medical
officers of the
of the devolved administrations and met
them regularly and I expect you'll want
to talk about that I was head of Doc
profession for doctors in the in the
government but part of the collective
leadership of Medicine with presidents
of Royal colleges
so I think that probably gives you a
feel for it yes that is a broad scoop
IFA Mississippi
very broadly within your functions and
you've just referred to these two
general categories you are responsible
therefore for health protection
in that very broad categorization do we
include matters such as
Health emergencies
the risk of infectious diseases
pathogenic pandemics
antimicrobial resistance all things
which pose a threat by virtue of Hazard
to the health protection of England
I was not responsible I advised on all
those issues and cared about them
because I care about the public patience
for me as a doctor always came first but
I needed to get the advice from experts
such as public health England Academia
I didn't in fact suggest that you were
primarily or anything solely responsible
for those areas I was asking you whether
or not
the broad nature of the functions that
you discharge could be divided into
those two categories yes Health
protection
and health Improvement yes right so
under Health protection AMR Health
emergencies
pandemic
outbreaks that the risk of pathogenic
disease and so on and what is health
Improvement concerned with health
Improvement
well
one reason we had a bad outcome from
covid
and I presume would get from flu but we
have thankfully not tried it is because
of what you have been told the health
inequalities I would talk about the lack
of resilience in the Public's health
25 of children in year six are obese 60
of adults are obese or overweight we
have high levels of diabetes it's the
health Improvement is how does
government play a role improving the
health of people because there is a
libertarian view that it's all down to
each of us as individuals and um how
strong we are but of course it isn't
about that it is much more about the
structure of our society and how to make
the Healthy Choice the Easy Choice
whether it's activity or what we eat or
anything else
are you able to say What proportion of
your time was spent advising on health
protection as opposed to health
Improvement or is that an impossible
question
it's so varied from month to month
I mean it I'll take novichok again
because I mentioned it over the period
of a month I did nothing but novichok
um and the Russians poisoning people
um but other times I could do more for
instance
um when the the policy team were
thinking about obesity then they would
come and consult me I discussed with the
treasury the framing and the work on the
sugar Levy I set up a challenge meeting
inviting cabinet office prime minister's
office as well as our policy teams with
academics around obesity
both to hear the latest evidence but to
model to people in government that I
could say I didn't know please help me
please tell me and that seemed to me
important not only the information but
the style of how you go about making
policy what do you mean by a challenge
meeting
I um got in people who were expert at
things and we would structure it so they
would give short interventions with
slides and then allow policy makers to
say but we thought this or we want to do
this my lady or them to say you seem to
be going policy makers in this direction
and our evidence that suggests that this
doesn't work or you'd be better doing
the following so trying to get a
constructive
challenging in in a constructive way
discussions on some subjects
may I now ask you
to put
the position of chief medical officer
structurally into the right place in the
overarching nature of
the government by which I mean
the CMO does not sit in any government
department but was there any kind of
administrative structure around you an
office for example
and to what extent were you obliged to
liaise
with government departments whether it
be the Department of Health whether it
be the cabinet office the department of
leveling up housing communities
and so on
so the chief medical officer sits in the
Department of Health Now dhsc supported
by a small team as I said only 13 in
total in the Department of Health
working
mostly on health with health but working
also with the cabinet office number 10
and other departments I did quite a bit
of work with
um diffid and the foreign office because
of global Health not only do I care how
people live in their health around the
world but our best insurance to nasty
things coming here is making sure they
don't overwhelm those countries and then
move
before you were chief medical officer
as I summarized earlier you were Chief
Scientific Advisor in the department
what was then the Department of Health
is the role of chief medical officer
equivalent
at all to the role of a departmental
Chief Scientific Advisor or does it have
a greater degree of Independence
oh the CMO has
at least as I was total independence of
thought and my ability to advise
the chief Scientific Advisor is there to
advise their department and in that role
I would try and help policy teams and
ministers know what the latest science
was or if they'd commissioned something
look at it for some sanity or recommend
peer reviewers of course it was me in
2000 I was appointed in 2004 at director
General level who persuaded government
to let me set up the National Institute
of Health research so that we had much
more applied research and Science and so
that we could develop the infrastructure
that then saved many lives of the nihr
managed no managed clinical research
networks which were the networks that
ran all the trials that gave us
treatments that worked ran the trials to
show whether vaccines worked so I as CSA
did most on setting up nihr and making
it effective and deliver for the nation
and the nation's Health more than
looking inwards
as the chief Scientific Advisor to the
Department of Health and as a director
General in the Department of Health were
you
more closely concerned therefore with
work streams with work being done within
the Department of Health
as opposed to the dischargeable
functions latterly as chief medical
officer
no I ran the R directorate but I didn't
have any other directorates I attended
the board and things like that and
contributed but they are moderately
independent
managed I was performance managed by the
chief by the permanent secretary and of
course I think you will have heard
something about holding but the whole
point of how we
commission research in this country is
that the politicians can not only set
the budget but decide on big areas they
want investment but they can't decide
where the money goes indeed one of my
clashes with ministers was when they
didn't like a recommendation that I had
to clear with them
uh which had been put
um advised by an International Panel and
I had to say it is your right to
overrule me but if you do I will resign
I was not overruled
no one in this country could be
unfamiliar now with sage
the scientific Advisory Group connected
with emergencies
what is the role of the chief medical
officer when it comes to Sage where Sage
is dealing with a major health emergency
so when I started in 2010
the pandemic 910 of flu was declared
over in fact in that first winter of
Christmas
2010 11. I realized I was in wave three
of the flu pandemic
um
um we've also reviewed how things had
gone in the 910 pandemic and one of the
things that came out of it was that the
sage had been chaired by the
government's Chief Scientific Advisor
and though our chief Scientific Advisor
me at that time had gone to Sage this
wasn't a very good way of knitting
together all the different bits of
advice and trying to make it as
effective as it should be I would sit
there and listen in Sage to people
talking about well is it safe to
transfuse blood or something and I'd say
but we have an expert committee sampto
we have to ask them because they know
what they're talking about so we then
discussed it and um over the next couple
of years came to an agreement that when
there was a medical emergency or an
emergency with health impact that the
CMO would co-chair
so in fact you participated in sage in a
number of different roles and with a
number of hats on because you were
initially a participant in Sage because
you were the Department of Health
Chief Scientific Advisor that was in
relation to swine through the 2009
pandemic
then in relation to Ebola
you were on Sage or rather pre-sage
yes then after that you participated in
the stage that was convened to deal with
the novice poisoning in Salisbury
Amesbury because by then you were the
chief medical officer of England
correct and is is it part of the role of
the chief medical officer to to provide
technical insight and guidance and of
course advice to Sage as well as
chairing it or co-chairing it to the
event of a major health emergency
well a CMO
I'm quite careful about what I really
know and what I don't so if it came into
my personal expertise I would put it in
but in general I went to those meetings
briefed not only by public health
England and other experts but also aware
of the situation in the NHS and so I was
there bringing that understanding and
the kind of common sense as a doctor
who'd worked with patients and the
system for many many years
so to some extent a clinical view as
well yes
the you've said Dame Sally you've
reminded us that um you're an expert in
hematology where
a CMO co-chairs a health convened Sage
May that Sage call upon not just the
assistance the expertise of the
attendance of that particular meeting so
in your case you're hematological
experience
but the expertise of of everybody at the
meeting but also of a number of other
bodies subcommittees and advisory groups
who who may be staffed with maybe start
by experts in other different fields I
was very
strong that we should where we had an
existing expert committee call on them
and we did
could we have on the screen
204-104 would you please help us James
with getting our bearings in relation to
some of the bodies which gave advice in
in the field of
Health emergencies
this is well it's now familiarly become
known as the spaghetti child but it's it
is a schematic representation Dame Sally
of
most not all of the bodies concerned in
pandemic preparedness and response
structures in the United Kingdom and
England this is not the chart relating
to Scotland Wells or Northern Ireland
and and it's
it Faithfully attempts to recreate the
position as at August 2019.
um
it's actually quite difficult to to
alight upon any particular name in the
mass of names and bodies but towards the
top of the page in yellow you will see
Cobra the cabinet office briefing rooms
and underneath that you will see the
chief medical officer England and that
was you at the relevant time
to the right government Chief Scientific
Advisor
did the government Chief Scientific
Advisor co-chair sage in the event of a
health emergency
yes
and underneath the CMO and the
gcsa weekend there see Sage
scientific Advisory Group for
emergencies
what were
because we're going to agree to more
about them in due course spy B to the
left and spy m o to the right
so I should say that it was the
government's Chi Scientific Advisor who
was the senior chair because their
office provided the Secretariat for sage
and they ran all the other sages
the Spy B was a group that could be set
up on Behavior
so trying to advise on how the public
might respond to various issues it arose
during the Ebola for 14 15 time when we
realized that anthropologists and
ethnography were terribly important to
the response and was reconvened
thereafter with sages when needed
definitely in covid spy m is the
modeling subgroup o because
um during covid it was active out of an
emergency it's just spy M it brings
together modelers here which talking
about infectious diseases but you can
model any emergency whether it's
flooding or anything else
from the relevant departments with
academic that's coming in and the
objective was to bring their different
models and and come with a consensus
agreement to Sage that then generally
the gcsa would take into Cobra the
modeling all right and when you say spy
m o was active does that mean it was
operational hence oh yes and spy B is
the group in relation to behaviors
thank you and therefore spy B
on the right hand side of the page you
will see the reference to other
government departments and underneath
that box departmental Chief scientific
advisors
you've referred already to the
government's
Chief Scientific Advisor but did major
government departments have their own
internal Chief scientific advisors
almost all of them did and they met
weekly with the chief scientific
advisors so it was
a broad Network
at the top left hand side of the page
you will see nerve tag new and emerging
respiratory virus threats Advisory Group
was that a body which reported into
Sage when required but also
permanently gave advice on as it says on
the tin respiratory virus threats
as it says on the tin yes new and
emerging respiratory threats
um not predicting what might appear
they're reported into the department of
myself as chief medical officer we took
their advice into sage and cobra
I
I well with this but it is because of
course it's a three-dimensional
spaghetti mess yes um and I would just
say that the office of the chief medical
officer supported the chief medical
officer and the deputy chief medical
officer so I would have put them all
together I would have put them kind of
much closer to the Department of Health
but not fully in it and I do want to
point out that I worked as does my
successor very closely with the CMOS in
the Devils as well yes well there is a
yes there's no direct link is there on
the chart between chief medical officers
for each devolved nation and the office
of the chief medical officer I think
we've got to add a few links with
yes yes but I can't even read the
dimensional I can't even pray in Aid or
dotted line
don't Link at all but it is an important
connection
um so we can see that Dame Sally chief
medical officers for each devolved
nation and of course that includes all
all the nations
um further down the page so to the right
of chief medical officers for each
devolved Nation but above the big blue
box in the middle there is something
called the moral and ethical Advisory
Group miyag was that also a permanent
body which provided advice on moral and
ethical matters
no that was set up much more recently it
may be permanent now but um that was not
as far as I'm aware present uh through
most of my time right it is permanent
but it but it wasn't in place you're
quite right in the in the currency of
your throughout the currency of your
holding of the post of CMO and then in
the middle
because this is a health emergency the
lead government department is the
department for Health and Social care
and within that blue box just to the
right of the marked up passage dhse
Chief Scientific Advisor so there's the
CSA for the Department of Health and
Social care
who reported to the CMO
um and then if you really want to add to
your things of course the health
protection research units you've got
bottom left are funded by the nihr it
was money that I took from public health
England because I wasn't happy enough
with their research and I didn't feel
that they linked enough to Academia so I
took 20 million and following discussion
with them and policy leads chose
subjects and we commissioned a series in
their recommissioned every five years of
Health protection research units run
commissioned out of nihr
right
and then just above there we can see
above the the words operational Response
Center
which is a part of the Department of
Health and Social care which came into
existence latterly you can see director
of emergency preparedness and health
protection
that is one of the major directorates in
the Department of Health and Social care
is it not yes all right
somewhere on this chart will be Public
Health England or the United Kingdom
Health Security Agency oh yes
thank you very much my my eyes are
beginning to to Cross Public Health
England dhsc could you just very shortly
explain what was then the function of
Public Health England
Public Health England was a result of
the health and search Health and Social
Care Act it brought together the health
protection
agency and another of other bodies I
think we're about 70 but essentially
bringing together both Health protection
and health Improvement
both
as an advisory body on policy and issues
but particularly as a delivery body for
public health they had responsibility
for assisting local authorities in
appointing their directors of Public
Health in local authorities and they
played a major role in pandemics and
health exercises and Dame Sally is it
public health England that was
subsequently
abolished on its functions divided
between the United Kingdom Health
security agencies which you've already
referred and a number of other bodies
including yeah the jhsc NHS and Regional
Health authorities all right
and then finally on this chart towards
the right hand side of the page up
against the departmental chief
scientific advisors and all the
government departments they're under
we can see three
groups in in faint yellow the UK's
eunices animal diseases and infections
group The advisory committee on
dangerous pathogens acdp and has the
human animal infections and risk
surveillance group
do they all broadly speaking
do what they say on the tin yes
I'm sorry forgive the comment but some
of us may get the impression
occasionally that there's change for
change sake and
names of different groups or bodies um
what was the rationale between
bringing together Health protection
um and
help with with public health England
um
and then separating it again with other
bodies I mean why
my lady they were both political
decisions
um there is a rationale for putting all
of the Public's Health together
um because then uh you you have a
critical mass and things like data
um collection and processing all sorts
of things can inform each other and our
Public Health specialty as they train
has three
um pillars I imagine they call them that
they train in one is Health protection
ones Health Improvement ones uh health
services so people could move between
them so Jenny Harris was doing Health
protection in in public health England I
appointed her as my Deputy on health
Improvement and as a regional director
of Public Health she was rather good she
managed both
so they were trained in all of them so
that was it I presume that the splitting
again going back to what was there
before Public Health England was an
effort to really have a
not just a focus but a grip on response
for emergencies
thank you
finally
I think I may have said finally already
but finally finally
there's an important part of the
Public Health structure which is
reflected in this chart which is the
local directors of Public Health towards
the bottom of the page in the middle
below NHS England
who are directors of Public Health
they are a wonderful
community of some wonderful people who
are either doctors or specialists in
public health and they have trained in
their three areas that I've talked about
many of them are epidemiologists
and they are situated in local
authorities this was a change that was
brought in in the 2012 Act
it's reminiscent of
um the middle of the last century when
Public Health was a local issue and
public health directors were the local
medical officers and they looked after
outbreaks and
um
food health safety and things there
so it sounds a really good idea but of
course the government gave budgets with
them to local authorities and they were
very vulnerable and they ended up cut so
I think they have found it a very
difficult role
you referred to the 2012 act in fiscal
terms and as far as the directors
of Public Health were concerned did that
act
transfer
fiscal responsibility for those
directors away from central government
to local Authority and that of course is
why you refer to the fact that local
authorities then controlled the budget
so if local Authority budgets are cut
equally the budgets of their local
directors of Public Health occurred
that was in effect what
budget went from the Department of
Health to Public Health England at least
this is how I understood it and then out
to the directors of Public Health and
became part of the local Authority
budget Public Health England collected
the data and accounted for it but it was
cut by local authorities when they
needed saving
given what you said earlier about the
important functions of the CMO including
Health Improvement
as well as
Public Health
to what extent does the CMO England and
Scotland and Wells Northern Ireland
collaborate with and engage with local
directors of Public Health
so the structures were different in the
other devolves and they had roles within
the NHS which in their nhs's which I
didn't I met at least once a year with
directs the Public Health by sharing a
conference with the association of
directors of Public Health I met the
president or chair of the
association of directors of Public
Health more often
I tried some phone-ins but not many
people phoned in so if I met them they
said oh so I suppose
I face very similar issues to you
because I would talk about how you have
to try and persuade politicians to put
money into things or to recognize the
importance of a policy and I would talk
about how difficult it could be and
they'd say that's exactly what happens
to me so we we had similar jobs but I
didn't have a strong relationship
what about with local authorities more
generally so for example my lady said
evidence about local resilience forums
who play an important part locally in
civil contingency there on the bottom of
the chart at the bottom left
were there any meaningful links between
the office of the chief medical officer
or the chief medical officer and them no
those links were either with public
health England or with um the eprr
program
and and finally on this topic the
devault Administrations
you had regular meetings did you not
with the CMOS and the deputy CMOS of the
devolved administrations and no doubt
you had meetings with
the
the the national analog of Public Health
England so Public Health Wales and
public health agency in Northern Ireland
and health protection Scotland were they
all bodies with human communities at
some point I regularly met in different
ways with members of Public Health
England I did not have accountability
meetings with public health England that
sat with the right director General I
met just with the CMOS we met four times
a year formerly had dinner before to try
and build trust and I involved them in
many projects so when I was asked by
David Cameron to write guidelines on
alcohol consumption I asked them to join
me the same with physical activity the
same with the report on screen time
because doing the work together made it
much more powerful it built our
relationships for when there were
difficult times and actually it's much
easier for you citizens across the UK if
it's one set of guidelines for the whole
of the UK so I did quite a lot of work
with them as did my office and the civil
servants whether from public health
England or the department who were
leading bits of this work on my behalf
thank you very much could we now turn to
the issue of risk assessment
but ladies heard a considerable amount
of evidence concerning
what is now known as the National
Security risk assessment process
and
you were CMO until October of
2019 I think the National Security
risk assessment for 2019 what was
approved in July of that year prior to
you leaving the office of chief medical
officer in October
2019.
do you recall
having any input into or debating or
discussing the draft 2019 National
Security risk assessment
I don't recall to be honest but on the
other hand
um a lot of
documents went past me
and I don't have the world's greatest
memory which is why I've had to bring
some notes
um
and if I thought it was all right it
would be likely to stick
a point made by the cabinet office both
in writing and orally before this
inquiry last week
was that the risk assessment process
particularly the National Security risk
assessment for 2019 was subject to a
considerable degree of external
validation checking
and it was examined by departmental
Chief scientific advisors
I create policy subject experts external
experts
the scientific pandemic influenza
Groupon modeling
the risk assessment Steering group rasg
and what are known as expert challenge
groups to which you referred earlier
did they include the CMO
not that I recall but it's the CSA at
that time was Professor Chris witty was
there I would not feel the need I
trusted him
um
and it he was CSA
I mean there's a limit to the
duplication no indeed
um
the chief medical officer of course
after you as you said as an expert
in in epidemiology
one of the major risks that in fact the
primary risk of tier one risk the the
highest overall risk in that entire risk
assessment process was of influenza
pandemic
was closely related to the issue of
epidemiology
do you think there was a case for
involving or maybe now involving the
office of the chief medical officer in
that risk assessment process in order to
to ask the right questions to to
challenge and to prove
I think it
it does depend on who is the CSA and who
is the CMO I would be surprised if I
could second-guess Chris witty I did do
know that I made sure that antimicrobial
resistance stayed on the list
um because I've had such trouble trying
to raise awareness of this
in your witness statement you say will
you express your belief that
the UK's preparations for a pandemic of
influenza reflected a long-standing bias
in our preparations in favor of
influenza
and diseases that had already occurred
with we now know an underestimation of
the impact of Novel and particularly
zoonotic disease
part
of that underestimation
or an explanation for that explanation
underestimation main part be found in
that risk assessment process
which focused on pandemic influenza as
you know and arguably fail to give
sufficient attention to the risks of
other pandemic
pathogens
and of their varying characteristics
which may include different incubation
periods
asymptomatic transmission
higher Transmissions greater severity in
the zone you're familiar with the issues
why do you think that long-standing bias
occurred and or was allowed
to continue
so
I've said previously something about
groupthink and there was group think but
it wasn't just us this was the whole
Global North the Western World thought
that flu was the thing to focus on and
let me be quite clear we've had in just
over a century four flu pandemics we
will have more it's only a question of
when so for me the issue is not should
we not prepare for flu we must prepare
for flu the question is what else we do
over and above that
um and clearly
we could have done more thinking so we
needed
the system which included me in that way
needed more challenge I tried I um
following a visit to Hong Kong where I
learned a lot about SARS I did ask
unofficially what about doing a SARS
review and was told oh no it won't come
here and I found in a document that is
you have uh someone's given me in an
Evidence pack i n q four zeros five six
two five six the national research
the search register National risk
assessment
um and from January 16 that it actually
says about SARS more recently MERS and
Ebola that they were unlikely to present
a wider threat to the UK through
sustained spread so I
I mean that was what I was being told I
went to Korea I came back and I asked
for a MERS uh practice and we did
exercise Alice you may come to yes so I
did put some challenge into it but maybe
this is the moment to say how sorry I am
to the relatives who lost their
families
it wasn't just the deaths it was the way
they died it was horrible and I heard a
lot about it from my daughter on the
front line as a young doctor in Scotland
it was harrowing
it's horrible
indeed
in September of 2019
John Hopkins Center for Health security
published a paper entitled preparedness
for a high impact respiratory pathogen
pandemic
can we have please 198
I think page six please
198 916
the report examined from a well-known
renowned
body the current state of preparedness
just on the eve of the pandemic
for pandemics caused by high impact
respiratory pathogens that is pathogens
with potential for widespread
transmission and high observed mortality
where a high impact respiratory pathogen
to emerge either naturally or as the
result of accidental or deliberate
release
it would likely have significant Public
Health economic social and political
consequences
novel high impact respiratory pathogens
so just pausing that not just of course
influenza
have a combination of qualities that
contribute to their potential to
initiate a pandemic
the combined possibilities of short
incubation periods and asymptomatic
spread can result in very small windows
for interrupting transmission making
such an outbreak difficult to contain
and of course Dame Sally are longer
incubation period whilst one is becoming
infected which is asymptomatic so that
one doesn't know one is infected gives
an even greater potential to spread an
infection before one becomes aware of
the symptoms
the potential for high impact
respiratory pathogens to affect many
countries at once will likely require
International approaches
and the article goes on
to raise a general concern about the
lack of global attention and
consideration of this threat and and it
calls
for a general a better understanding of
levels of preparedness structures and
capabilities and observes that there are
notable existing gaps
in this field of
pathogenic learning
it was well understood wasn't it that
the next
pathogenic pandemic
could have very different
characteristics not just influenza but
differences in terms of transmission
incubation period and asymptomatic
infection
you must have given a very great deal of
thought
to this issue
why
does did that whole process of risk
assessment of preparing producing
influenza strategies of preparing work
streams to deal with the consequences
the impact of a influenza pandemic
not address that feature
I think the answer is in two halves
so
the first is of course
it was this group that said we in the
states were in a wonderful position and
top of along with the who top of the
charts for our pandemic flu preparation
which do you mean by that the reference
to the Johns Hopkins no the the
um
the grading carried out under the
awesomenesses of the World Health
Organization The Joint evaluation and
also the GH SI yeah right so
you know that reassured me as a
non-expert
um but part of that part of the answer
is the
first of all
I believe that if we prepared well for
flu we should be able to Pivot pretty
effectively
um and we can't prepare for everything
meanwhile we did a lot of learning as we
went so after 9 10 there was the Heinen
review and that 2011
pandemic plan I came into my role was to
consult on it to consult widely and no
one said oh you've got it wrong
um we were hoping to update it or at
least the department was intending to in
a in about 2014 but then Ebola came but
we learned during Ebola
about things we the public health
England on behalf of government put in
place uh screening at the airport looked
at and modeled quarantining in a hotel
and some other facility which didn't
sound very nice but they they did do
pieces of work that I knew we could call
on I knew that during Ebola because we
would inevitably import some cases that
because of the pressure I put on the NHS
they had had to make sure they're not
only in 2015 had
reliable PPE but I was assured
by the chief medical director that they
had been trained to use that effectively
so I went forward believing that we had
quite a bit of the other things that we
might need in place
Public Health England was advising on
the PPE stockpile
the second part of the answer is yes we
did not have
the government didn't do the plans but
we didn't have resilience either and as
I said earlier you can't get a good
outcome if you don't have resilience in
the Public's Health resilience in the
public health system it had been
disinvested in resilience in the NHS and
by comparator data compared to similar
countries per hun per 100 000 population
we were at the bottom of the table on
number of doctors number of nurses
number of beds number of itus number of
respirators ventilators we needed
resilience in Social care that was
clearly missing
resilience in the Life Sciences about
manufacturing we didn't have that the
only thing we had resilience in and I'm
very proud of and it did save millions
of lives across the world was r d
but if we don't fill those no plan will
work Dave said you could just explain
what you mean
you mean by do you mean the the clinical
expertise the scientific and research
basis
basis so following Ebola
um led by Oliver letwin some
um considerable amount of money more
than 400 million
um official development assistance was
made available and we set up I think it
was 110 million the vaccines Network to
look at what we could do and I turned
the first meeting then Chris Whitty took
over to help prepare for infections that
didn't have vaccines that might occur in
low and middle income countries might
spill over we funded into Oxford for a
MERS vaccine that was the basis of the
successful
Oxford Cambridge AstraZeneca vaccine
that saved more lives probably across
the world than the other ones we had
um
I'm having to think of all the different
things also we put put in place after
Ebola a rapid support unit which was
co-commissioned out of the London School
of hygiene and tropical medicine and
public health England on the grounds
that if you get
snuff out something that happens quickly
it's much better and cheaper and they
would go at who or country request all
around the world to help countries on
breakouts of
Ebola cholera things like that
um we I put in place the um the search
units we had the research networks to
deliver all of the
um the clinical trials
I know I've got more I should tell you
all right I can't remember it rather
than turning this into a memory test but
let me say it's a very impressive answer
but we'll come back to some of the
specifics a little later thank you but
is it therefore just standing back in
terms of
to use your expression the pillars of
the United Kingdom's ability to respond
and
its response
the three areas appear to be that the
question of resilience
by which you've spoken information very
eloquently
the issue of research and development
the scientific and research base which
led to diagnostic tests being made
available extremely quickly
vaccines of course antivirals clinical
treatment the trials and and all the the
data research from Vivaldi and Zoe in
the various systems that were put in
place and then the third area is I
suppose countermeasures
the political and administrative system
which was designed to prepare the the
country for a possible pandemic
and it's in relation to the areas of
resilience and countermeasures that you
have spoken in the terms that you have
in your witness statement
the
pandemic preparedness strategy 2011 to
which you've referred two two seven zero
eight
Dame's honey I dare say that that when
the the the strategy came to you for
your review you said you had an input
into it of course it was
it called itself the influenza pandemic
strategy so I don't suppose anybody was
thinking about what other pandemics this
strategy document should be designed to
address
I was not it was the beginning of my
period I had a lot to learn page 15.
says this
the pandemic is most likely to be caused
by a new subtype of the influenza A
virus but the plans could be adapted and
deployed for scenarios such as an
outbreak if another infectious disease
for example SARS in healthcare settings
I pause that in healthcare settings
because SARS wasn't generally understood
to be something that was capable of
spreading Beyond Healthcare settings
with an altogether different pattern of
in factivity is that the same point that
you made earlier which is that you
understood that the
strategy was to have a plan for
influenza which could then be adapted
for the purposes of a non-influenza
pandemic
this was written by my predecessor
um
who knew much more about this than me I
I mean looking at it now
I still think that some of the plan is
was very useful and can be very useful
but there was more we should have done
do you recall any debate when you were
the chief medical officer on the need to
update this
single there was no other strategy for
influenza pandemic this single strategy
or to produce
a strategy document relating to
non-influenza pandemics
no but I suppose in a way that's why I
wanted I mean practices because
do you need something else written and
long what you need is the people who
will be involved to learn lessons and
know how to put it into practice so I
asked after the German outbreak of E
coli where a number of children died
that we should do an E coli exercise I
asked about SARS I I initiated by asking
for it the most one
as far as you are aware
did anybody stand up and say well
did this strategy is solely Reliant upon
a pandemic influenza there appears to be
no strategy document dealing with
non-influenza where are they where is
that document
I can remember no one saying that to me
I think I would remember that
in your witness statement turning now to
a to a different topic you
say this as a system we need to open
ourselves up better to challenge
including from external experts
you will know from your your
comprehensive review of the
documentation that the Department of
Health and Social Security after
covid pandemic acknowledges that the
department would have benefited from a
fuller understanding of the response by
Asian countries of course the responses
to their experiences of SARS and MERS
which both of which had had repeated
outbreaks
can you assist the inquiry pleases to
again you must have given us a great
deal of thought as to how we can better
learn
from the experience of other other
countries other systems and and perhaps
overseas experts because that appears to
have been missing
in the system at the time
so we need to continue to engage
with who and through who we build
relationships with other countries we
have two quite useful systems one is
um called ghsi Global Health security
initiative which is G7 Health ministers
plus Mexico who have met a number of
times and we've done exercises with the
ministers and their senior advisors that
those have been useful
G20 when Germany was chair we did an
exercise in Berlin on Ebola that was
very important for the health ministers
islands and things I actually went and
ran one on antimicrobial resistance for
the Argentinian G20 that they found very
useful
um but I also think we need to look at
how we bring in
external Challenge and it is something
about an open policy approach
which I was clearly made for in that I
love to have a debate and see if someone
can best me and make me change my mind
occasionally yes
and and so Dean Sally have you
identified there for a
a second important
doctrinal approach that that can no
longer be the level of group think to
which you referred earlier
but there must be more external
Challenge and are doing a way of would
you describe as United Kingdom
exceptionalism the belief utterly
offended that we know better
I absolutely agree but I would also say
that as we
we have a limited amount of money and
limited people both in the policy space
and in the delivery space whether it's
the NHS or public health and so we also
have to well listening
with respect to some of our academic
colleagues who come up with things and
say yes but what is the risk of that
happening is that something that we need
to do a special plan for or can we do
can we amend a plan
I mean it's clear that no one thought
about lockdown I still think we should
have locked down the first time though a
week earlier but during that we should
have thought do we need to further
the damage I now see to children and
students from covid and the educational
impact tells me that education has a
terrific amount of work to do we have
damaged a generation and it is awful as
head of a college in Cambridge watching
these young people struggle and I know
in the preschool they haven't learned
how to socialize and play properly they
haven't learned how to read at school
we must have plans for those well they
damn Sally of course are all terrible
consequences from the lockdown itself
but
for the purposes of this module the
position
laws wasn't it
that the possibility of a lockdown
itself was neither foreseen nor planned
for
that is the reality isn't it and it was
through that failure
in the context of planning for a
pandemic
is one of the more notable
failures in this strategic planning
I still yeah
all right
I'm sorry we didn't plan for that
I'd
I think we
I would prefer to
to have planned
to not get us to that stage but we
didn't recognize that it could something
could get to that stage and then how
would we manage it the other thing
another thing which I would say we
didn't plan for was flu has some Peaks
that go for 12 to 16 weeks we never
planned for something that was on
remitting for a couple of years it may I
mean may not have gone away yet we could
have some more mutations the risk
assessment document to which you
referred
talks only in terms of a 15 minute wave
and the impact of that on both the
public but the front lines
we had to think about how we should
scale
both scale effectively but then maintain
that response
and while I'm on it we should
as a government
have and well I'm not government but I
wish that someone had looked at
Logistics and thought about
logistics and Supply chains and data
better may we come back to that in the
context of some of the recommendations
from Alice insignos which of course deal
with that
you referred a few moments ago
to the failure to think more about how
to prevent
is that a reference to perhaps a further
doctrinal era or a strategic error which
was the focus on trying to deal with the
assumed
catastrophic consequences of an
emergency as opposed to trying to
prevent those catastrophic consequences
from occurring in the first place
what did you mean by that
yes that was what I was referring to
that we worked on response
and I do not remember a conversation
about so how do we stop it getting here
in part because the international Health
regulations of the who to which almost
every country signed up to say that when
a pandemic kicks off you do not close
the borders
but I did learn during Ebola
some important lessons so
the government David Cameron wanted to
look at closing borders Public Health
England said it wasn't cost effective
and what I learned was
there are times when you have to do
things that may not look cost effective
because the nation needs them
may now turned to exercise Alice in
cygnus you you will be of course very
familiar with with both exercises not
least because
the evidence before the inquiry says
that exercise Alice was prompted by a
request from you personally
and it was a tabletop exercise conducted
in in February of 2016 in London to deal
with the assumed large-scale outbreak of
MERS Coronavirus
and it was a very significant exercise
was it not yes
the objectives of the exercise were to
play me
observe and confirm the health
capabilities and capacities of
of our country
to explore and Report upon the
communications and the control
mechanisms
as to how this emergency would be dealt
with and also public messaging and
contact tracing and so on and so forth
but two very important parts of exercise
Alice and and the report
dealt with the the possible need I
emphasize possible need for Mass contact
tracing
if MERS
the assumed exercise would get out of
control
and not just be confined to health
settings and also the possible need for
for large scale quarantining again
if the virus were to get out of control
and and were to overwhelm
that
the relatively small
systems for dealing with high
consequence infectious diseases which
are basically run by public health
England and and Specialists who go in
and sort out the problem
can you recall now
why
the work streams that were designed to
to give effect to the exercise Alice
recommendations a particularly in
relation to quarantining and Mass
contact tracing don't appear to have
borne fruit
know I instigated it I felt we needed it
if you look uh at the report you'll see
it was published written by public
health England my
understanding was having written the
report which of course I saw
um I participated and saw that they
would get on and make sure that they
addressed the agreed recommendations it
wasn't me saying I think you should do
this no it was the report yeah from them
so
looking back
does it appear to be the case that the
the system
for which of course you're not
personally responsible but the system
failed to ensure
that within a reasonable amount of time
practically the recommendations of
exercise Alice were put into place that
plans were drawn up along the lines of
those recommendations
I would have expected them to be
um it appears they weren't
in relation to
exercise Alice after it was complete
and and it in general terms it
set out and highlighted a number of
areas in which recommendations
were made and areas in which
improvements were were suggested
do you recall any debate
at the level of the office of the CMO
as to how progress was being made
in terms of putting those
recommendations into place no
all right
um
you must understand I was terrifically
hard worked
and um actually spent rather a lot of
time on another Health Emergency the
antimicrobial resistance pandemic
let me make absolutely plain the
survived four anticipate
that the chief medical officer should
oversee this process and and make sure
it was put into place I merely inquiries
whether or not the system happened to
provide for the CMO to be told as of
progress and and what was happening I
don't recall it
um
Jeremy Hunt in his witness statement
um and and will be hearing from Mr hunt
tomorrow
says he was not involved in exercise
Alice and neither the department that's
the Department of Health and Social care
nor the chief medical officer believe
any recommendations from the exercise
reached his desk which rather suggests
that he's asked you or he's made some
inquiries as to whether or not you knew
whether that the recommendations had had
not reached his desk
so I developed
a trusting relationship
with that particular Secretary of State
and felt that I should get on with my
work and go to him when I needed to I
asked for this there were good
recommendations I
don't think I did take it to him because
it seemed to me the work was done he
shouldn't he was busy he didn't need to
worry about it
and you could sensibly presume that the
system would be in place to ensure the
recommendations were acted upon and the
steps are taken
exercise cygnus
was was an even bigger exercise was it
not it was a tier one National level
pandemic influenza exercise in October
of the same year with near on a thousand
Representatives
um
and it was designed to test the United
Kingdom's preparedness response to a
pandemic influenza outbreak commissioned
by the Department of Health
and Commissioned I think at a stage when
you would by then have ceased being the
chief Scientific Advisor in the
department of health I say this
advisedly you are merely at that stage
just the CMO but you weren't directly
engaged within the Department of Health
to what extent were you aware of the
outcome of exercise cygnus
um
there was a one-day exercise Signet that
set up cygnus yes
itself went for three days in October I
was uh part of that in receiving both
briefings briefing the Secretary of
State and going to the mock cobras and
commenting and Advising
the report makes plain that you yourself
had called for more regular programs of
tier one pandemic flu exercises yes is
that correct along with the permanent
secretary who agreed with me
and it was your position and you
publicly stated it that it was essential
to build on the learnings from exercise
cygnus to ensure continuity in the
country's preparedness and you suggested
that in future tier one pandemic fear
exercises
be conducted coinciding with the
beginning of every new Parliament which
would ensure regular and significant
exercises
yes
do you know what came of your public and
consistent recommendation to that effect
[Music]
but we probably aren't in the new
Parliament and covert came but I don't
the conclusion from exercise signals
and milady's heard this
discuss stated a number of times is that
the United Kingdom's preparedness and
response in terms of its plans policies
and capability were not sufficient to
cope with extreme demands of a severe
pandemic
that would have a United kingdom-wide
impact
this was an exercise which at least
indirectly you had called for which you
promoted and you supported and you
wanted such exercises to take place more
regularly
were you extremely concerned by that
conclusion the conclusion of the process
to which you had lent your support
I thought it was
correct conclude vision
and I hoped that it would spur more work
it did set off some streams of work that
I
was concerned about
one being how if we our NHS is
overwhelmed should we triage the work
and that piece of work went through and
it was in fact that which set at which
precipitated or or pushed for the need
to have a medical and ethical group that
you referred to earlier
another piece was as we worked through
it and things were clearly out of
control
somebody representing a minister or a
minister or someone would say well we
could take emergency powers for and I
highlighted that we should work out what
were all these possible emergency powers
and draft
um a draft act so that we were prepared
and over the next two years that was
worked on
so I had feedback occasionally from
these civil services contingency on how
that was progressing very slowly and the
triage work from the NHS which I saw
through to a conclusion and shared with
ministers the other work I was not
particularly party to
and is that because James Hardy
the chief medical officer was not
expected and in no way expected to be
able to
supervise the outcome of the
recommendations whether they were
implemented let alone the work streams
which were designed to give effect those
recommendations
so some of the work streams came across
your desk because they happened to be
within the reach of the CMO so for
example one was
drafting a bill called the pandemic
the draft pandemic bill
to deal with providing the necessary
regulatory powers for a pandemic
although in the event
as we all know the lockdown regulations
in the main were promulgated under
earlier
Public Health legislation dating back to
1964.
a second work stream was dealing with
the medical and ethical consequences
flowing from the terrible decisions of
hospitals to have to triage patients a
third work stream was
dealing with surge capacity
a force was dealing with the impact in
prisons
were you aware
that of the 22 or so recommendations
only I think a bare majority were
actually completed or
in part
completed no I wasn't but
the CMO
has strength by being advisory and
independent
so there is a limit to what that office
can do when only 13 people she
advisor has a hundred people
team Sally just before you go into a
different subject I was going to ask one
more question yes on this one
um just generally and that in fact would
conclude by my examination oh right
you
have been good enough to provide my lady
with an with a number of observations
and thoughts and and suggestions in
relation to how this system could be
made better
are there any other General
recommendations or suggestions that
you'd like to make
that we've not touched upon yet
I
I think there were two issues as we went
through covid that I saw that I worried
about
and the first was that Sage is by
definition a biomedical model
could you explain what
um so it is about science and about
health and very
practical and evidence-based
and
it was
where the behavior groups by B came in
on Behavior
they just opined based on no evidence
that the public wouldn't like lockdowns
so they wouldn't do it there was no
evidence
and what they should have said was there
is no evidence you will want to consider
um and it seemed to me that sitting
outside it all which
gives you some advantages in thinking
and challenging of course that what we
needed to do was balance the biomedical
model with the economic and social that
ministers and government need to be
presented not only with the biomedical
advice
but also what's the impact on the
economy on the social cohesion of our
community and on education and so we
needed as a nation a second group
advising on all of that and I
I wondered whether you would use just as
we have the chief Scientific Advisor
perhaps the chief Economist from the
treasury and the bank of England to
bring in education well-being and all of
those things because I don't think we
cons as a nation consider those issues
effectively
the other very big concern I had as we
went through this was data
and how it was handled to help the
nation do better I mean to find that
public health England were collecting
data into Excel spreadsheets and didn't
is bad but then didn't know they only
had 300 lines so data dropped off the
bottom and they didn't know that they'd
lost some patience at one point is
appalling but we weren't as far as I
could see
um accessing and using all data so
before I go on let me just say I was
very quiet about
uh covered because it seemed to me that
a lot of people were commentating and I
know from when I was CMO that you know a
lot because people are synthesizing
stuff and there's data and that many
people were setting themselves up as
experts on television who weren't and
very few external people knew the whole
picture so I was Keen not to the only
time I did make comment
um was once in the Telegraph and that
taught me I shouldn't do it again
um
though the reason I did it perhaps I
could just say this was because I'd
written a book I thought that covid
would start a debate on the health of
our public and inequalities and I wanted
to contribute to that and I'd written a
book and I brought you a copy your lady
to give to you thank you very much for
your summer reading okay I thought you
might find it interesting about these
issues
so I was quite careful but the other
thing I did do because I didn't think we
were using data well is I raised seven
and a half million pounds and set up a
charity called the Trinity challenge
to look at how we could use data from
different sources better to predict a
pandemic diagnose it prevent it manage
it and we got 340 applications from 62
countries and we have the most amazing
Prize winners from all around the world
um not using data differently that could
then help our response one of the second
prize winners was
from Cambridge our mathematicians 3.4
billion blood counts are done across the
world the printout looks like when I was
a student which was decades ago
80 done on a Japanese technology where
under the decks there's a black box with
70 more parameters
using data from Adam Brooks Hospital in
Cambridge from the year before covert
and then covert they think they've found
a covet signature just imagine using AI
you can find that so then as people come
in you can stream them you can triage
the winner was a Taiwan where they
Farmers photographed sick and dead
animals and send it to a vet who then
begin to put data together and advise
them because it matters to them
economically but thinking about diseases
in animals that could hop to humans and
visit if needed so I felt we could use
data
better and differently and I think as we
go forward we need not only to fund to
work across government to make
um and it will be statutory what's
needed to make the resilience of the
public health
Pro right
but also we're going to have to fund
much better data probably in partnership
with academics because governments find
it difficult to be at The Cutting Edge I
remember
quite early in the pandemic some of our
Cambridge mathematicians coming to me
saying the modelings it's out of date
and it's for flu we can do much better
so I asked them to go for the Royal
Society and then they were brought in by
Patrick Valance into the modeling and
then we had much better modeling but we
have to find ways to work much better
with
The Cutting Edge of our superb academics
mayor be permitted to thank you for
those thoughts I I should say that
they're all areas which Milady will be
addressing in module two so specifically
data
the biodiver the diversity and makeup of
sage and and modeling
um
but if I may ask you one further
question
tie some of the points that you've made
to this module and and preparedness
you've referred to the fact that
the advisors and experts who are having
to Grapple with covid
may have failed to pay sufficient regard
to behavioral change the an issue that
in essence the issue if I can put it
perhaps rather crudely the possibility
that
the country and it
would react instinctively to the need to
protect themselves from covid and
therefore
an issue arose as to whether or not a
lockdown is required because the
populace might just
self-isolate naturally and in any event
was behavioral change something that had
come out of a survey of
South Korea's response to the MERS
pandemic and which was the subject of a
specific recommendation in exercise
Alice which was the
assumed MERS exercise in the United
Kingdom
I don't think I know what you're getting
at what I would say is came out of
um out of both SARS and MERS in Asia was
the desire when there's a respiratory
risk to wear a mask
and who would not recommend masks
because we're in no randomized
controlled trials well blow me you can't
do a randomized control trial properly
because you don't know whether someone's
infected or not you don't know whether
they're wearing them properly or not but
common sense says
that wearing masks
will give some protection and actually I
think that's where the science has ended
up so that came out of MERS and SARS but
that was the issue of Behavioral change
was something that was flagged up in the
exercise Alice report yeah but very
little appears to be done in relation to
taking that thought or that
work stream to user a word beloved of
the bureaucracy further thereafter
true and I think I'm arguing by saying
we need a separate committee that thinks
about behavior and Society so that it's
not locked into health behavior people
but is a much broader Church of experts
I'm sorry for for telling my back I do
apologize I was just receiving a message
um milady
I believe there's been a request under a
rule 10 -4
me to ask a question about exercise
sickness if I may if I may do that
um
I think the evidence shows that exercise
cygnus was originally planned for 2014.
but was delayed
for a number of reasons can you recall
why the carrying out of exercise
sickness was delayed well 14 15 was when
we had Ebola wasn't it 14 to 16 was when
Ebola was in West Africa we mobilized we
were asked by the Sierra Leone
government to lead
or to support them in their response
they had many cases many deaths we
mobilized a hospital ship we mobilized
military on the ground to build
hospitals and diagnose diagnosis and
treatment centers we sent NHS staff I
mean we learned a lot
but but it delayed the exercise what was
there also not a uh a strike by Junior
doctors around about the same time which
impacted upon the operational date of
the exercise
if you don't if you that would not as
far as I'm concerned have impacted doing
an exercise but I think they were
contemporary
my lady those are all the questions that
I have for
Dame Sally thank you very much thank you
very much indeed and Sally I'm very
grateful and I shall read your book
summer reading you said rather than
bedtime reading yes
thank you very much indeed for your help
and for your work thank you my lady that
concludes the evidence for today
very good apologies sonographer going on
over the hour and a quarter hope she'll
forgive us
um very well 10 o'clock tomorrow morning
yes
please thank you
foreign
[Music]